pete's sick made in china
i mean
oh
i wish to exp uh express appreciation to
the people who run the building
uh for our wonderful valentine presence
of new
um
what whatever these are yeah thank you
because i have a button on mine that uh
apparently you don't
my button kills every mic
at least in this room if not the entire
building
tyranny
revolutionary
okay
begins the hearing we begin the hearing
on house bill 1481 repealing the statute
relative to medical freedom in
immunization
and the chair recognizes the prime
sponsor of the bill representative
thank you much mr chair i'm um
i'm uh the prime sponsor hb 1481 an act
repealing the statute relative to
medical freedom and immunizations
which from what i've seen is probably
doing something somewhat different than
what the other bills you're hearing
today will be doing in fact
so
start out by so i'm represented timothy
horrigan from stratfor county district
six the towns of durham and madbury and
uh durham is the
home of the university of new hampshire
which is
uh
somewhat related to the reason why i
introduced this bill but this
so there is no first one i'm going to
say there is no natural legal or
constitutional right
to spread any communicable disease
especially not a respiratory virus like
covet 19 which has killed over 900 000
americans
when the within a few weeks this death
toll is
will surpass uh a million
so this that makes it the worst
catastrophe in the u.s history in terms
of uh loss of life since uh in fact i
think it's the worst catastrophe even
worse than the civil war
the worldwide death toll of 5.8 million
and counting and it probably won't be
so the uh can you hear me okay
okay good so i can leave my leave my
mask on um
it's not a hundred percent the covet the
covet vaccines may not be 100 effective
safe but they're very good there's a lot
we don't know about the virus
yet but we do know for sure that it's
extraordinarily dangerous and there
still is no cure for it
and of course also because it's a
respiratory virus um you know it's being
spread through the air you know we're
all breathing the same air regardless of
what letter we have after our name or
whether we're wearing a mask or whether
we're vaccinated or not
so
um
you know so it's extraordinarily
dangerous and pervasive you know it's
everywhere in the planet
so i represent durham the home of unh
like other colleges and university
universities unh has taken a very
aggressive approach
to fighting the pandemic
really even before the state of
emergency beginning with masking up and
social distancing continuing with
testing for the virus
and they're still doing both those
things
and then since and when the covet
vaccines became available which was
almost exactly a year ago unh has done
everything its power to make sure that
uh
everyone in his close-knit student body
as well as the faculty of uh and staff
gets gets immunized
at least as many of them as possible
if unh was a private school it could
have necessarily simply enact a rule
requiring everyone on campus who can be
vaccinated
to get vaccinated um i know dartmouth
has instituted a similar role
however since unh is a public
institution is forbidden by rsa 141 c1a
from taking that step and this makes no
sense
so our other
our public college university has the
same responsibilities as any other
institution when it comes to protecting
their students and employees from covet
they should have the right to require
vaccinations if that is what's needed
and that um the same
the same also goes for um
non-educational government institutions
as well you know this uh this doesn't
just
you know this rsa that i'm trying to
take off the books
doesn't just cover educational
institutions it covers like all all
government
government agencies and i think all of
them have the responsibility the rights
to do what they can to protect
the people their employees their staff
and the people who use their services
from covet 19 and i i don't think the
current law does that so that's uh
that's uh so that that's what that's
what my bill does the effective date
um
effective date is not to january 1st
2024 but you're certainly if you like
the bill i think that's too far in the
future you're welcome to move up the
effective date if you'd like so
with that i'd be happy to take any
questions
any questions for the representative
representative gay sheriff
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question are you aware of the
other rule the alternate that unh offers
its students
that they must be tested frequently if
they don't and also are you aware that
i mean i not sure the second part of the
question i'm not sure exactly what you
mean by natural immunity um i mean they
they encourage
they have a very extensive testing
program they've had it i'm going on its
third year now that's uh
still going on i think they're
encouraging even people who have been
vaccinated and boosted to continue to
get tested continue to mask up to
continue you know
continue to deserve other precautions in
as i said there's a lot we don't know
about it but i think it takes you know
there have been cases of people who've
caught the disease which i guess you
mean the people who've caught the
disease and uh survived it um and
so they have obviously
it's obviously they get immunity from
that for a while but the vex i think the
vax the vaccines uh provide uh
additional additional immunity so um
i don't know is that what you mean by
not quote unquote not respecting natural
immunity so
like what do you maybe want to clarify
follow-up
yes natural immunity is the immunity one
acquires when when one is
is sick and are you aware that the cdc
has said they are not aware of anyone
who has caught it from someone who
i would be i'd be very surprised i guess
i'm not aware of the cdc saying that i
would be very surprised because i think
i've heard
i've i think i've heard stories of uh
exact opposite happening and people
catching
people uh
people can catching covet and then
catching it another time in spite of
their natural immunity so i know there's
definitely been cases of that so i'm
basically
but that's true i'm not if they've said
it i'm not aware of it and i think i've
heard him say the exact opposite but
thank you mr chairman
instead of
repealing the whole
um rsa 141c1 which is the medical
freedom immunization
thoughts on adding this to
the latter part of it which says it
doesn't apply to nursing homes new
hampshire state hospital or the medical
facility would it be simpler to just add
a line in there that says that's
unapplied to a state university well in
terms of accomplishing that particular
goal yes and in fact
i was also a co-sponsor of a similar
bill the prime sponsor was
representative of
jefferson shapiro who's sitting next to
you and um that
that one was sent to house education
rather than this committee so um and so
yes it would be
that would have been uh that would have
been simpler so that was the first idea
that several of us had including
representative shapiro had it first and
um but i also figured it was worth uh
worth doing the same thing for for
all government institutions all of which
all of which have a responsibility to
you know protect themselves from uh from
the virus and i don't think they can do
so effectively with the law the way it
is but yes it would be simpler um
whether or not you'd want to amend it
that way if there's already an identical
bill in education that's a question
you'd have to ask the clerk but and
yourselves but representative merchant
may absolutely be simpler yes thank you
mr chairman also thank you
representative for taking the question
in regards to
by inserting it here it does not
preclude a university for men requiring
it just means it's not required by the
law
so therefore it still allows the
flexibility for them like other private
institutions or private and
business people to
apply it if they want to it's just that
they're not required
well if you had that other bill and um
which is in in education had a hearing i
think last week so um
yes that would that'd be another way to
approach the problem and in fact that's
already been considered by a different
committee and
probably
um
i don't know why the deputy speaker
sent that bill to education instead of
here but that was what happened so
thanks
thank you
thank you mr mr
chairman careful
um i'm prepping for wednesday
i hope you're not here
okay i'm all set uh so the question is
uh i'm reading uh rsa141-c1a
yeah and it starts out every person has
the natural essential and an inherent
right to bodily integrity
what's your opinion of bodily integrity
well that's uh that's the phrase we
interpreted in lots of ways it was even
uh used in a
pro reproductive choice constitutional
amendment last year which i'm which was
probably uh
which is probably not the intent of uh
of this spill but certainly
you know the virus the virus is also a
threat to our body is a threat to my
bodily integrities i've certainly felt
like my bodily integrity has been
threatened every day for you know the
past
two plus years so um
yeah so i think yeah we there is a
inherent right to bodily integrity i'm
not not sure uh not sure whether
immunizations threaten that bodily
integrity seems to me the
seems to me a respiratory global
respiratory pandemic is is a pretty
great threat to all of our bodily
integrity even though
some some some people not necessarily
those in the room but some people
outside room seem to be in a pretty
i guess he wants
i'd be happy to answer a follow-up if
you want to give him one mr chair
would you like a follow-up you may have
so
uh
would you also agree that there's
protecting our
our bodily integrity that immunization
is one way of doing that
oh well i suppose i guess i wouldn't
disagree with that the way you stated no
so
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question if um if this bill
were to pass
would any
would this require any
body to be vaccinated or would it
would it allow
institutions like
like the public universities you're
talking about
um
to require it in the future should it be
necessary uh well wouldn't
it wouldn't directly require anyone to
be vaccinated there may be cases where
that becomes difficult for someone to go
vaccinated and certainly um
like i've um the you know i know i i
checked
like i checked just for example
dartmouth's policy and they do allow you
to apply for an exemption and uh so that
would probably that would probably be
what the educational institutions would
uh would would implement um
but uh
and of course a lot of cases you're not
you're free to leave that institution or
not deal with it or certainly in terms
of
public-facing government institutions
they usually have alternate ways of
accessing their services um
including something simple as you know
masking up when you go there or
accessing the services remotely so i
don't think um you know
i don't think any i don't think uh i
don't think any government institution
education otherwise is going to be able
to totally shut out people who you know
chosen not to get vaccinated or
thank you
any other questions for the
representative
thank you very much representative thank
you
the chair recognizes lisa
lipkin
who wants three minutes she has written
testimony
and she opposes the bill if you would
pass out your written testimony
okay then you can give the copy to the
clerk afterwards
microphone
okay thank you very much for offering
the opportunity for public comment um
and i didn't come
armed with many many facts of figures
and data so i wasn't planning to speak
about that but i will say that the claim
that covet 19 is the worst health crisis
of our time or any time it has very very
questionable data underpinning that and
i would be happy to offer that i could
do some research and provide the data
that to back up that statement um after
today uh what i did come to speak about
was in um opposition of bill 1481
um i'd also like to quote from the
statute which it's seeking to repeal hb
220.
that every person has the natural
essential
and inherent right to bodily integrity
which i think is not hard to question to
understand what bodily integrity is
free from any threat or compulsion
any threat or compulsion by government
i will note
that every single elected representative
including each one of you took an oath
when you assumed your role as
representative
for the people
you said i do solemnly swear i will bear
faith and true allegiance to the united
states of america and the state of new
hampshire and will support the
constitution thereof so help me god i
know you probably know these words by
heart
that means each of you has personally
sworn
so help you god
to uphold the constitution of this state
the new hampshire constitution states in
its very first article all men
people
are born equal
equally free and independent
therefore all government of right
originates from the people is founded in
consent
and instituted for general good
a person who is coerced
into taking an injection or a medical
procedure of any kind especially this
one which has very questionable positive
benefits and a lot of science to support
that it is very harmful
but a person who is coerced into taking
any injection
against their will is by definition not
in consent
and those in government who would do
that coercion are acting in direct
violation of their oath of office the
right to bodily autonomy is an
inalienable right it should be an
embarrassment forgive me please it
should be an embarrassment to this body
to have this bill put before the public
there is nothing more fundamental to a
free people than the freedom to choose
what goes into their bodies
attempting to remove that rightful
freedom is inhumane
immoral and definitely unconstitutional
in upholding your oath of office i will
look forward to seeing each of you
reject
hb1481 thank you
would you be willing to take any
questions from the representatives here
sure if i can answer i don't have data
with me i apologize uh representative
cushman thank you mr chairman thank you
for um taking my question i
i'm just wondering
what are your thoughts about um
other state governments um instituting
mandates and coercing people have you
been aware of of that occurring anywhere
else sure i mean i'm aware of the
attempts to do it i think it's been shot
down quite a bit
um i just i mean it follows the same i
can't even believe that in our time that
we are actually questioning whether a
person has the right to decide what goes
in their bodies period i don't even
think i can't believe anywhere in this
country we could even be debating that
especially when there is actual science
and there are there are people who have
been greatly harmed by this vaccine that
are desperately trying to speak out and
get notice and be uh respected for the
true harms that have been done to them
this is
you know crazy to me
thank you anyone else
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
there's a lot of focus on rights which i
totally support
at the same time this also comes with
rights as responsibilities
so can you speak to help me understand
the issue about responsibilities if
someone likes not to take the vaccine
which is their right
sure however they're also responsibility
to protect those around them
by either wearing a mask or mitigating
the transmission of that disease can you
speak to the responsibility side of that
equation
sure and i think representative king
kind of touched on that when he said
what are the ways that a person may be
able to protect themselves so certainly
anyone that feels comfortable and feels
better about
being vaccinated should have the right
and freedom to do that so
the premise of a vaccine is that it
protects the person who's vaccinated so
to me that would be the primary
protection if somebody was of that
mindset and wanted to do that i'm
certainly again a mask you know again a
lot of there's a lot of questionable
science behind a lot of what is going on
but um people are free to wear masks
people are free to
stay away from each other there's all
kinds of things that one can do to
protect oneself if one is feeling
threatened but but it's almost like you
know there's that expression um
uh your
rights don't end at the beginning of my
fear or something like that you know
it's that like just because you're
afraid doesn't mean you can infringe on
my
right to breathe freely to trust in my
immune system there's so much there are
actually a very large amount of natural
remedies that people can take to
strengthen their immune system to stay
well and then should anybody
get sick there are um excellent remedies
that do not involve hospitals or
injections where they can be healthy so
there's it's a much bigger story i think
than just the the narrow cast that this
is dangerous and we need to protect
ourselves at all costs no matter what
the danger might be in the protection
in
speaking to the question about
rights
uh and responsibilities
your answer was mostly about your rights
i was looking in my bag to see if i had
a copy of the new hampshire constitution
i with me i don't
but early on it talks about how in
society
in order to gain some rights
which we get when we live in society we
have to give up some rights
so that is where the rights of other
people besides ourselves start to kick
in well again i don't think anybody
would want to infringe on anyone else's
right to protect themselves you know i'm
not saying uh nobody should be masked
and nobody should be vaccinated and i
have the right to impose that on anyone
i'm saying everyone has the right to
their own sense their own bodily sense
and even when it's based in science
supporting their
sense and their common sense um to
handle their health however they feel
so you know it gets very uh murky there
when you start putting other people as
responsible for your responsibility for
your own health i'm taking
responsibility for my health you have a
right to take responsibility for your
health
representative canuck
thank you very much
uh given the fact that one of those very
important parts of vaccination is not
just protection of the person who's
vaccinated
but protection of others around them
because of the fact that some people are
vulnerable uh may
not have a good immune system that
allows that gives them a good response
when they are vaccinated or may be
medically unable to be vaccinated or
to remember actually none of our
vaccines are 100 effective that one of
the most important parts of high levels
of vaccination are protection of others
in society not just protection of the
person who's vaccinated
and i have i just happen to have that
what our chair was looking for
you quoted the constitution a lot but
part one article three says when men
enter into a state of society they
surrender up some of their natural
rights to that society in order to
ensure the protection of others so given
that a high vaccination rate is
protective and we have that in the
constitution
why is this not acceptable to
enforce vaccine mandates if necessary to
protect others
well again i think there are a few
issues in what you said um
it the cdc itself has told us that the
vaccine is does not stop spread and does
not stop
actually getting sick so so again there
we could be having a whole conversation
about the actual science of this
particular vaccine but i didn't come
prepared to speak about that um so you
know does one give up rights in order to
be
um you know a citizen that works in in
beneficial ways with others
um that again would be something i'd
have to look at i mean what is you know
a right
you know you're talking about the the
right for someone to impose a medical
invention intervention on someone else
without their full without their consent
with other true consent i mean that gets
into nuremberg issues so i don't think
we can talk we can sort of make it sound
like yeah well i don't you know i don't
have the right to throw my garbage on
the street because that isn't polite and
it makes a dirty street and it's not
good for others but you're saying you
know when there are when it is possible
for one to protect oneself as i said
before have remedies there's all kinds
of ways to not be at risk
by my actions you personally do not have
to be in any risk based on my
health choices that's just a fact so so
we you know
then it goes all the way into this again
about bodily bodily autonomy integrity
there's a risk if there is a risk and it
is known that there are risks and it's
been proven that there are risks because
people have been greatly harmed by this
vaccine if there's a risk there must be
genuine full sovereign consent
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
so
are you
of the mind that
our bodies and what we put in them and
all of the things that we're dealing
with right now for rights are natural
rights
um in here in article four
it says
among the natural rights some are in
their very nature unalienable do you
believe that
those rights are unalienable i
absolutely do right because no
equivalent can be given or received for
them of this kind are the rights of
conscience so
i hear you saying
that you're thinking that that our
rights are rights of conscience am i
correct in my assumptions yes and bodily
integrity yes and the right to research
and study and discover for ourselves and
use critical thinking and and talk to
these 25 doctors and put their testimony
next to these 25 doctors and decide for
ourselves so yes conscience for our own
very lives
thank you thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question have you found it extremely
difficult in the regular media to find
contradictory information or has it been
pretty much one-sided and leaving those
of us who disagree pretty much out in
the cold i could have said that verbatim
yes absolutely extraordinarily one-sided
and not only one-sided but doctors
doctors with
nobel prize backgrounds and triple board
certified and highly regarded and
respected prior to 2020
are censored
being censored
and trying to speak out so yes very
one-sided and and
frightening rather actually for those of
us that have other that are are studying
this in a more objective way
thank you for your testimony appreciate
your coming very much chair recognizes
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members
russ sanchester from bedford new
hampshire
i am a vaccine injured individual not
from the coven 19 vaccine however
i did suffer a vaccine injury so i'm
here to tell you that they happen
first of all second of all the bottom
line is what is happening right now is a
division and an isolation
so the unvaccinated are being identified
as dangerous the vaccinated are being
identified as fearful
and that's being perpetrated on us by
our government and our mainstream mostly
our main street meter but i think it's
all really connected if we go back five
years ago who in this room could
honestly say that they believe that big
pharmaceutical companies really had our
best interests at heart
anyone
if we go back five years ago
would we believe
that when someone knocked on the door
and said i'm here from the government
and i'm here to help would we have
believed you
would anyone in this room have believed
what we're being told
we believed in our doctors
over time we've lost that trust and i
think it's been perpetrated on the
american people by
some of our doctors who either have
bought into the propaganda of only one
side and i'm not saying that both sides
aren't full of propaganda i don't know
because i'm not being
allowed to use my critical thinking
skills and really identify
what is the truth
in the last couple of years we've been
we've heard a lot about it's my truth
just because you my truth doesn't mean
it's truth
and that's something that we all have to
take into account now i just wanted to
say like i have
um excerpts from a confidential briefing
to congress of 7 29 22
that talks about the vaccine and
of 469 cases in one county in
massachusetts where 79 percent were
symptomatic and breakthrough cases from
the vaccine to me that doesn't sound
like something that is
it's questionable um
the cdc estimates if i can't say it um
maybe 75 to 85 effective 75 to 85
percent against a new variant rather
than 94
against the original so i mean you can
find the information but it's not easy
i have from the cdc website itself i
have two pages of
some of the side effects from these
vaccines
i'm going to ask the witness to hold up
for a minute you're a frequent flyer and
we give you frequent flyer points for it
thank you but we know your testimony
okay and we have other things to do okay
so so i appreciate you coming and could
you i'll give you two minutes to two
whole minutes less than two minutes i
promise or fewer okay okay um so as a as
a uh i just wanted to speak a little bit
as a vaccine-injured individual do i
feel i'm being discriminated against
right now yes because when i walk around
without a mask i'm looked at funny when
i put a mask on i have reactions
i have a lot of um skin reactions now
since my vaccine injury so i'm in a
position where yes i'm being
discriminated against because i'm looked
at as
something other than
appropriate
however at the same time i choose
sometimes because of my immune
deficiency issues i choose to allow
myself to be discriminated against
on purpose i can make the choice as an
unvaccinated person i can make the
choice to not put myself
at the super bowl
i can make the choice not to put myself
in the vi in an environment where people
are coughing and sneezing and and i may
be at risk i can choose not to put
myself in a hospital emergency room
where there are a lot of chance of me
becoming infected with not only the
coven 19 vaccine cover nitin virus but
any other virus or illness that's
transferable common flu
so that being said i just wanted to say
from someone who was vaccine injured
our rights are our rights they shouldn't
be trampled on and um
and we can choose
as our individuals
how to protect ourselves and others
thank you so much for your testimony
i think
i'll take care of that thank you that
it's not your responsibility to do that
representative soloway um just a quick
question ms chester thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question but i uh always need to rely on
people who give testimony for the
accuracy of their facts you identified a
document that you quoted and you dated
it 7 29 22 21 can i look oh i was
looking forward to the publication of
that
i did that last time i did that before
too thank you thank you good good good
thank you so much and with that no more
pink cards i'm closing the hearing on
which means
we can do
some
executing
and i'll start with the one that i think
will be real easy for us so i'm opening
an executive session
on house bill 1320 an act relative to
public exposure of deceased human bodies
and your
tell us what you'd like us to know this
is an exact session it does not have to
okay thank you very much
just to review for people because there
still is some confusion about
the bill itself is simply to repeal the
current statute
the current statute is a little bit
confusing as written no dead human body
shall be exposed to the public for a
period in excess of 24 hours and a said
body is properly embalmed
um
it is actually confusing enough that i
was surprised that one of the funeral
directors actually misstated its meaning
in their uh in their testimony
um i'm trying to i'm sorry i wasn't
quite ready to state it but well
whatever one of them actually even
misstated it saying it was if it's more
than 24 hours before it's exposed and
that is not of course what it says
now the important part of what this is
trying to do
is simply giving to the consumer
i'm not quite sure i guess the consumer
is the family but the consumer being the
deceased person who may have made their
arrangements prior to becoming deceased
the choice of what they want to do as to
whether they wish to become embalmed or
not
and it is not something which is
necessary from a public health point of
view which is why we heard it here in
this committee
there was a question brought up by the
chair of whether we should have a
disclaimer because we saw that there was
this confusion and have some kind of a
form
this was generated partly by his
discussion with the funeral director he
knows he asked us to reach out i
disagreed for reasons i'll say in a
moment and i reached out to the funeral
advocacy people representative woods
reached out to the funeral director but
the things that came back from them were
vastly different and this was going to
totally cut out the
the organization of funeral directors
from any of the crafting of any
disclaimer
my concern is that that really would
massively expand the scope of the bill
we were we were hearing a bill that had
public health implications making a
decision
if we put in a form that has to be
mandated then we're actually tampering
in commerce and regulating that that
industry which is the purview of
commerce
committee not us that's not our
specialty and they might not be happy
with that and i would think it's also
disrespectful of the funeral directors
who would not have had a chance to
comment about that since that was not
what the bill was about the chair agrees
representative thank you so yes yeah we
had some conversations so we kind of
agreed that at the end of the day we
should not expand it a good option maybe
for another year and just keep it simple
again the reason for the repeal is
simply to give people a choice that it's
not presented in a misleading fashion
and we don't
the the
the statute only guides the rules and
regulations it allows the
funeral directors to
do whatever they want they may say we
offer like there's ads in our paper
sometimes about we offer cremation they
could say we offer refrigeration if you
want to not be embalmed and have a green
burial we offer refrigeration and you
can have a viewing you can even have a
viewing without
uh preservation or with refrigeration
just for a few days till you get there
that viewing probably ought to be done
fairly soon if you do that but the point
is these are choices
that the consumer works out with the
funeral home
and the funeral home can set their own
policies this doesn't tell them what
they have to do it doesn't preclude them
from embalming
and so they set their policies and the
consumer can choose which funeral home
they wish to go to so that's really what
it's all about uh do you want me to make
a motion
i should have made that first perhaps
well the chair actually has your name
down thinking about what your motion
might be so go ahead and i would just
move a simple otp
and the chair will second that
now we can discuss further
representative gay
thank you
i'm still puzzled because of the
simplicity of the wording here
i wish it said that the
funeral directors
have a right
to do whatever they want to offer
whatever services they want which i'm
told
is true
but i don't see it here
and the my own director the
person i know the most who is a funeral
director
is quite concerned
because
she didn't see that protection in there
representative connect on a follow-up
then representative weber yes if it is
not prohibited by statute
that is a right that they have
um we also
don't i mean we would have to a pretty
big set of rsas if we had to tell
everybody what they could do
so the issue is if it is prohibited in a
statute you can't do it if it's not
prohibited you can so this is they have
every right
within the limits of what rules are set
but that's a different issue
thank you thank you i was going to make
essentially the same point but the the
way i always make it is there is no law
allowing me to brush my teeth in the
morning i do it every day anyway and
nobody's prosecuted me yet
we appreciate yes
as we are
as we
all are thankful to one another yes okay
any other
seeing none with the clerk please call
the roll the motion
on house bill 1320
ought to pass by representative canaric
seconded by the chair
representative leon
yes representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes representative king yes
representative cole fault yes
representative delemus
yes
representative weber representative
mckay
representative snow is absent
representative knurk
yes representative salloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
20 to 0. 20-0 any objection to consent
do we have the readout of the numbers
oh
the numbers of people who signed up
i
totally forgot to download that
i can look that up right now okay
we should have done that before but you
could do that now and uh
but no objection to consent
okay thank you and representative kenner
if you would write the committee report
yes i will of course thank you there
were 21 signed in and support six signed
and with that
i close the exact session on house bill
representative cofolt um are you able to
do you need to go for a minute you do
need to go
okay wrong folder
yes
mr didn't see on the list of bills you
wanted to consider to exact one was 1466
which was the op label
there is an amendment that
put forth by
leon cushman myself and woods
it was not on the list because i didn't
prepare for it is there any would
anybody object to starting this
discussion and maybe maybe then proceed
to a vote um
okay then let me open thank you let me
open in the exact session on house bill
when was that hurt you gave it to
everybody
there's
there was an amendment passed out last
week i don't know whether people have it
or not so the amendment is coming around
and i'll need to look on for the
see there we go look at that
i don't know if the what
if the vice chair wants to speak to this
bill it was kind of you sort of drove
the amendment
but we will be
we're now there
uh once everybody has
all right with the vice chair please
explain the work of
four people on this with an amendment
zero four zero six
uh thank you mr chairman um we got
together as a group the four of us to um
to try and figure out how to respect
off-label practice while also making
sure that off-label practice doesn't
provide cover for bad behavior
as we looked to this
we realized that the language
could have provided that protection
because simply because they had
prescribed something off label so we
agreed upon language to say
the state of new hampshire confirms its
strong support for shared
decision-making between health care
professionals and their patients a
licensee may lawfully prescribe an
fda-approved drug product for an
off-label indication where there is
sound scientific medical evidence or
when the licensee has provided and
documented informed consent for the
patient including a disclosure that the
prescription is for an off-label
indication a licensee shall be held to
the same standard of care as when
prescribing for on label indications
the distinction between the two the
sound scientific medical evidence is
because there's a
huge amount of medicine is done off
label the cost of approval is just
astronomical and we don't want to
cheapen the informed consent when it's
something that is such routine care that
it just you just become blind to the
paperwork whenever there's debate or
discussion then it is appropriate to
obtain that informed written consent
it's a practice that i'd like to see
more of in general so i'm happy to see
this here
then also that puts it under the nurse
practitioners
the physicians and surgeons and
physicians assistants
and
it keeps the same part for the licensed
pharmacist to say that
that they should not face
non-disciplinary or disciplinary action
by the pharmacy board for filling a
valid prescription for an off-label use
that is within the part that talks about
actions so it's the right right section
of law because there are other parts
that are carved out there so this this
provides that protection it provides
that clarity and i think that this is a
great collaborative effort
so thank you for everybody who worked
together anyone else in the work group
wish to add anything before we throw it
open to everyone else representative
woods yeah thank you mr chair um i would
just add that
i was concerned about what the
relationship might be with the ama and
their code of medical ethics which
physicians are required to follow and
that's in statute it's referenced
and indeed there were a number of what
called the ama has a council on ethical
and judicial affairs which uh
uh offers opinions uh and and judgments
as well for that matter uh and um i
won't go bore you with all the details
but
the way this is now formulated is very
consistent with the outlined in the
ama's code of mythical medical
medical ethics
as well as
their most recent uh
opinions uh in
in in the pandemic as it's called
um so i just to clarify that this is i
feel more comfortable
the way excuse me the way this was
worded now that fits and will protect
not only the physicians but also the
patients
anyone else from the work group
with a comment
okay anybody else representative shapiro
i looked up the numbers the original
bill 79 supported this bill and 20 were
opposed
this is
i think this is a great collaboration
and a good solution this is just a kind
of a grammatical a question
where it says
where there is sound scientific medical
evidence
it doesn't really say evidence of what
representative leon
actually i'll defer to representative
burch representative merchant
the reference to that is sound medical
evidence to use it off label
there are a lot of times in which to
represent leon's
comment it's very expensive for a drug
company or somebody to go back to the
fda to get an approval for a particular
indication
and sometimes it's cost prohibitive but
there's many times in which drugs are
used off label in their studies to
document the use of it through the sound
medical evidence which is what that
refers to
representative shapiro
yeah i don't want to beat a dead horse
so this will be my last comment that was
the previous exact session
um
right
but are we talking about evidence of
efficacy are we talking about evidence
of safety
um i don't know what evidence of
off-label use would be exactly it's um
it's not explicit to what you're asking
for it's implied that the sound medical
evidence is for the off-label use of it
so therefore
it goes back to the efficacy of it as
well as the safety of it because the fda
looks at both things a drug has to be
both safe and efficacious so this is
basically saying to the prescriber that
you have to have some sound medical
evidence to support the safety side as
well as the efficacy side
thank you representative
just want to clarify one thing is my
major concern with the initial bill was
the prohibition against
any action by the medical board of
course it was limited at that point to
only that this one is much better to
have the various practitioners covered
um
what it appears is that in the section
on pharmacists there is an explicit
statement about the fact that a
pharmacist shall not face
non-disciplinary interdisciplinary
action revealing it filling a valid
prescription
that's good and i think the point is
since there's no prohibition in the
other sections for the boards to be able
to take action if somebody doesn't
follow good informed consent or if it's
something which there's no medical
evidence
that would still be allowed is that's my
interpretation is that what you're
could you condense down exactly what
that question was so in other words if a
practitioner
still did something that was really off
the wall there was no evidence
whatsoever for what they prescribed or
for which they
or they didn't get informed consent they
could still be disciplined by the board
i presume since this doesn't
prohibit that
um that that's my understanding good if
there's either that evidence or if there
is that informed consent that makes it
valid because otherwise it wouldn't be
valid right thank you representative
weber
and as a follow-up the last sentence in
the section on physicians and surgeons
says a licensee shall be held to the
same standard of care
as when prescribing on label
so
they need to be satisfied that they can
not only that they know what they're
doing but that they can satisfy their
board and if i may just as a matter of
follow-up mr chairman i will say that
when my late husband
was being treated for the prostate
cancer that was very advanced when it
was found
he was
when
there were no other interventions that
were available that he would accept
he was offered an experimental treatment
that he was told explicitly was a breast
cancer drug
that
might aid in pain control and might
prevent his bones from becoming brittle
and breaking
and he consented knowingly to that
because the side effects were very
limited
and
after he had been on that drug for a
year
the doctor asked him well you've been on
it for a year what do you want to do and
he said
i don't know what other people do and he
said nobody's been on it this long and
at that time when he started he was the
only person
receiving that treatment and you know
you had to wait for it to come up from
the pharmacy and everything else
at the end of a year they were treating
a number
of similar patients with that medication
because they were finding
that not only did it aid indeed in pain
control and
not allowing brittle bones to break but
that the people who were receiving it
were doing better than anybody thought
they
might and so without understanding the
mechanism
they were documenting over time
the scientific knowledge that
this has helped a lot of people
with very little
downside risk
so
that's how science moves on and and i am
exceedingly grateful to it and uh
because we had four years that he
wouldn't have had otherwise
and um also i'm very grateful for the
work on this bill because it looks like
it's a very good balance and i thank
everybody who is involved
representative woods
uh thank you uh just to again to clarify
what this actually means when we're
saying that they're held to the same
standard i'll read just that one
sentence from the ama guide which is
what's required
by statute uh in opinion 9.6.6
prescribing and dispensing drugs and and
devices uh it reads his fault based
quotes based solely on medical
considerations
patient need
and reasonable expectation
of effectiveness for the particular
patient
unquote
that's the standard to which physicians
quotes
based solely on medical considerations
patient need
and reasonable expectations of
effectiveness
anyone else with a comment or question
okay seeing
uh
yes
the chair recognizes representative leon
for a motion on the amendment i move to
h
to house bill 1466.
chair recognizes representative merchant
i will second that motion thank you very
much
an opportunity for any further
you ready okay
we're voting now on the amendment
zero four zero six h to house bill 1466
moved by representative leon and
seconded by representative merchant with
the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus yes
representative weber
representative mckay yes representative
snow
representative knerk yes representative
followed
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
shapiro yes representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
21 to zero
the chair recognizes representative leon
for a motion
imove ought to pass as amended by
2022-0406-h
house bill 1466
representative woods
for a motion i second that a second yes
thank you
we have before us
house bill
is amended
by
zero four zero six h
moved by representative leon seconded by
representative wood
would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon
yes representative mcmahon
representative acton representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
yes representative weber
representative mckay yes representative
snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
21-0
any objection to consent
[Music]
representative leon for the committee
report
sends the hearing on how the executive
and the team is at full strength good
1099 prohibiting the department of
health and human services from requiring
vaccine passports for services and i'm
looking
that's what i have
does i do others have it
wow i feel special
thank you
10.99
sorry i was still writing notes okay
okay
i was paying attention
how's your computer doing
well i haven't turned it on
coming around
they don't have it
i have it
speak slowly
[Laughter]
this this was the bill to say that the
department of health and human services
could not require a vaccine passport
in order for
the person in question to receive any of
the benefits that they might receive
administered by the department of health
and human services
and you may remember that there was
testimony that the department felt that
the existing language
in the statute already
required that
but that perhaps it was not as clear as
it might be
so
on
sort of the min do do the least that
needs to be done to make it clear
principle
it seemed to me that the issue is not so
much the vaccine passport as requiring
the vaccine itself because that's what
people don't want
if they don't want it and that is fair
enough
so
the existing statute already says no
person may be compelled to receive an
immunization for covid19 in order to
secure receiver access any public
facility
any public benefit or any public service
from the state of new hampshire
the department already believed they
were covered by that but in order to
make it absolutely clear to everybody
else
what i did was i simply inserted after
from the state of new hampshire
i changed the language to the new
hampshire department of health and human
services comma
or any political subdivision of the
state of new hampshire
in
so that's the new language including but
not limited to county cities towns
precincts water districts school
districts school administrative units or
quasi-public entities but that was all
language that was there so we don't need
to parse that
so my thought was that this made it
crystal clear
that if you are applying for food stamps
or one of the other benefits you you
you get that benefit if you qualify for
it without
and if i would
move the adoption of the amendment if
it's
moves the adoption of the amendment
second to representative soloway
thank you
my concern is
when i when i was looking at this
you've left off that
first
out of the amendment which says
communicable disease medical freedom and
immunization
vaccine passports prohibited
that
is
was not directed just at covid 19
and i think that's what people are
looking for is that when the next
infectious disease comes around
if we don't have that line in there all
of a sudden vaccine passports could be
required where this prevents
um vaccine passports
in general and if there's such a need
for it they can bring it before the
legislature at that point
to be able to get one madam clerk the
original bill as representative teroshan
filed it limited it to covet 19 line 5
of his original bill so the amendment
does not change anything
and they're the same language that's the
existing language in the existing
statute
in both cases it stays
that language stays the same
because in the original bill
all the bits that are not
bolded
that's the original this is the
amendment it doesn't change it but this
line right here okay
so you're addressing your question
to the header
which
in the original bill line one includes
the word vaccine passports prohibited
but in the amendment in line seven it
does not
but it does include medical freedom in
immunizations
broadly
so if you're not immunized you would not
thank you
my concern is that
everything is great about the amendment
except
it doesn't mention
not requiring a vaccine passport or
proof of vaccination whatever choice of
words it just doesn't say
that the department of health and human
services shall not require a vaccine
passport as a condition of eligibility
for our access to department programs
benefits or services representative
weber
but the point is
that what people are objecting to is
being subject to a vaccine that they
don't
want to put in their bodies
this acknowledges that they do not
have to put the vaccine in their bodies
in order to get the benefits
so there is no need for passports or
anything else because
whether you have the vaccine or whether
you don't have the vaccine you are
equally qualified to have benefits so
the fact the passport part of it becomes
irrelevant the important thing is that
you cannot be compelled
to accept a medical treatment that you
don't want in order to get the benefits
that you qualify for in it
completely
it's just
making clear that
vaccinated and unvaccinated people all
qualify for benefits and
vaccination status is irrelevant to
whether they qualify or not
representative
oh there we are it was flashing green
not red okay um yeah in fact i think the
current language of the stat of the
amendment is far clearer because
otherwise the original language was did
have vaccine passport what if they said
we have to be vaccinated but you don't
need a vaccine passport then we haven't
achieved what is really being desired
and as representative weber says the
objection is to being vaccinated whether
there's a piece of paper or not and
vaccine passports at this point are not
even
any entity that we have in existence so
i think the amendment is a cleaner way
to do it
representative leon
thank you mr chairman um
while it may be a cleaner way to do it
i already would read the department of
health and human services of being a
political subdivision
just as which which is already included
in existing law just as the universities
who have been having students show a
phone saying about their testing status
their vaccination status
so there is a value to clarifying that
vaccine passports are not accepted
it is something that is absolutely
moving not forward here in new hampshire
but in other places we are seeing these
standardized documentations and it's our
job to hold that line
when we look to the constitution in
article three of part one we've been
talking up until the semicolon but we
haven't included the last
those read and without such an
equivalent the surrender is void
so the entire statement is when men
enter into a state of society they
surrender up some of their natural
rights to that society in order to
ensure the protection of others and
without such an equivalent the surrender
is void
when we look at it now we we still are
seeing people who are catching covid
from people who've been vaccinated
because it's not a perfect vaccine if we
had a perfect vaccine i don't think that
there would be a debate about it because
people would be going out and getting it
but
right now it does not ensure the
protection of others
so the constitutional arguments i think
there go out the window but we have the
i really believe that we do need to move
this forward by keeping that language
about the vaccine passport for these
services especially because so many of
the services from dhhs aren't
necessarily the medical ones but all of
those other ones when you're already
dealing with vulnerable people who
some of them are there because they they
have trouble asserting their consent in
the first place because other people
have taken advantage of them and they're
being protected by the department and
they need to know that the state and the
department do
do reflect and do
representative merchant
yields to representative weber
but this bill is not about one's right
to consent it's about one's right to
representative leon
yes and it's about what may or may not
be required to receive that benefit when
we're dealing with people who
some already have a distrust of the
government
or when we're dealing with people who
trust absolutely everything the
government says and they would have gone
badly in previous times in history we
have to look at the fact that some
people
some people will feel coerced to have a
document if it's available
whether or not it's in the statutes and
whether or not their right is already
protected as it already is in the
i didn't
get a vaccine card
until i got my first shot
right and if i drew through the drove
through that line and they said you want
a vaccine and they said nah
they wouldn't have given me a card
so to me the vaccine passport
is a moot point for those who aren't
getting
vaccinated by their choice now
response representative weber
well i agree with that but i'm also
going to point out because the
university system was mentioned
as the men as hb 1099 was drafted
the amendment applies only to the
department of health and human services
it doesn't apply to anybody else
so and it's only for the purpose of
receiving benefits
and
the amendment
does exactly the same thing by making it
clear that you do not have to have a
vaccine
for anybody to
give your benefits i don't know why
anybody would ask in that case because
unlike
congregate living at a university or
medically frail people in a nursing home
there are plenty of other ways to
deal with the issue of applying for
benefits including applying for them
online which keep everybody safe which
goes back to the mutuality of the
surrender of
part of the natural rights
and it just makes sense that
bill
is completely contained in the amendment
there may be other places and other
issues where yes more language is needed
or more clarification is needed or more
balancing of the rights
of different people is needed
but that's not this this is just to
apply for benefits
that's all it's talking about the chair
would like to ask representative
am i correct
in saying
that you have taken representative
trojan's bill
and broadened
significantly
the freedoms
from just the department
to
any
political subdivision of the state of
new hampshire if anything you are
taking his bill
and making it a broader freedom
well i i would actually say that the
broader freedoms were already included
in the statute that we already have they
were already there
and this is not an area the
the benefits from the department of the
health health and human services
covered by the original statute which is
much broader
but
it's important to make it clear what
people's rights are
but yes the the provision that has been
inserted is a very limited provision
which limits a broader um
anything else we'll see if we can wrap
this up representative soloway
thank you mr chairman
there are really two pieces to this
one piece says
every by the way
this is based on the fact that
ultimately many of the pieces of
legislation that we pass
are tested in the courts
the courts go back to our debate
in order to make their decisions that's
correct if they take a look at this bill
at the amendment
it begins with every person has the
natural essential etc
to
free from any threat or compulsion by
government to accept an immunization
stop there
that covers us for all immunizations it
then speaks to immunization for covid
but that is only the particularity of
the general principle
that people
may be free from the compulsion to
accept immunization and therefore i
believe that this broader freedom
can be tested in the courts and will
stand scrutiny
anyone else representative cushman just
quickly two points
to representative soloway's
point the the new hampshire attorney
general
has
interpreted it to only apply to covet 19
this statute
and my second point is i
i think that this bill only serves as a
clarifier and i have no problem with
representative weber's amendment i think
that it satisfies what the
prime sponsor was looking to do
thank you representative gay
thank you i
agree that that representative weber's
wording is much more compact i am
concerned that we're removing in line
one
vaccine passports prohibited because
when we start talking about universities
somebody might not pre determine
that
um
that the list of any political
subdivision thereof including but not
limited county cities towns precincts
water districts school districts saus or
quasi public entities it doesn't say
universities there
and so either we keep adding
exclusions
or we leave in this general vaccine
passports prohibited
it is not clear
by those other exclusions that it
includes universities and i personally
am concerned about universities because
i don't want to see my granddaughter and
grandson have to get more boosters
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman that is existing
statute
what you were just reading it's already
there so that's already there this bill
by the i think it's inadequate
it doesn't say universities well that
would be
that's another other time and i believe
there's one in labor that
provides exemptions for university
students
sounds like representative gay your
argument would be with the sponsor of
the bill representative teroshan
and not with the amendment
the
representative weber the only thing that
representative corrosion's bill changes
is lines eight through eleven and that
speaks only to the department of health
and human services which does not
control the universities the
universities is a whole nother question
and that certainly
can be debated but not here because we
don't deal with the universities
unless it's a particular
i mean
what we have in front of us for the
original bill was much more limited
because it only spoke to dhhs
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman in the statute as
it is universities are not exempted
um so public ones public universities
are not exempted i know because i've
submitted a bill to have them exempted
um in another committee but as it stands
they're not exempted so it
a vaccine mandate at unh or keene state
college would not be allowed under the
bill as it is
i also wanted to just say that the
that the sign in on the original bill
was 600
the original bill without the amendment
thank you
seeing no further discussion we will now
move to a vote are we ready to vote on
amendments zero four nine one h two
house bill 1099 moved by representative
weber seconded by representative soloway
the clerk may call the role please
we need more of the mics off otherwise
mine won't work yeah
sorry
um okay no i can speak now
um
we're in the voting mode you either say
yes or no
no
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman
yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
cofoult
no
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon
representative nutter uppam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
the vote is 16 to 5 in favor of the
amendments
uh
i have you down for otp a are you still
willing to make that motion
chair recognizes representative cushman
for a motion
i motion to
um
ought to pass on hb 1099 as amended with
amendments
2022-0491
seeing none the motion before us
is on house bill 1099 as amended
by amendment 2022-0491
[Music]
h the otp a motion by representative
cushman and seconded by representative
weber
and the clerk
may call the role please representative
leon yes representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king
yes
representative kofalt yes representative
delemus
yes representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon
representative nutter uppam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
21-0
21-0 any objection to consent
seeing none and representative cushman
if you would write the committee report
please
closing the hearing on house bill 1099
we will have a about a five minute
recess before we resume with today's
any pink cards on house bill 1379 may
representative cofoult
just bring it to me and i'll fill it in
she also got a stain out of my shirt
earlier and
maybe we could get her a super clark
cape
opening the hearing now on house bill
i think it is
relative to the department of health and
human services rulemaking authority
regarding immunization requirements
and the chair recognizes the sponsor
member of this committee representative
cofoult
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is jim cofoult i am
a representative from hillsborough
county district four
representing wilton lineborough
greenville and francis town
i do have written testimony which i will
email to the committee and uh
in particular to the clerk uh following
my testimony
rsa141c20a
stipulates that certain immunizations
are required for children living in new
hampshire
immunizations for diphtheria mumps
pertussis polio rubella rubiola and
tetanus are specifically called out in
statute
the same rsa stipulates that the
commissioner of health and human
services shall adopt rules
relative to other diseases requiring
immunization
this has led to the addition of three
additional
immunization requirements uh that are
called out under administrative rule
these include varicella chickenpox
hib and hepatitis b
what was the second one
hiv it's uh
this bill is
not intended to argue for or against
any of these immunizations
personally i believe that the decision
to vaccinate one's children should
ultimately rest with the parents
but
if an immunization is to be required we
ought to acknowledge the gravity of that
decision
by vetting it through the legislative
process
with all of the scrutiny and
transparency that implies
in fact this bill does not preclude the
possibility of establishing immunization
requirements for children in our state
beyond those that are already in statute
it merely stipulates that decisions of
that magnitude
should be made by the full legislature
the decision to force a vaccine on
virtually every child in new hampshire
should not be taken lightly
under the rulemaking process the
commissioner has the power to propose a
rule
and barring a statutory objection by a
majority of the jail car the joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules
so let me acknowledge
a very obvious point i think which is
that we would not be discussing this
bill
if not for the fact that there are many
people around our state
around our country and throughout the
world who have serious concerns
about the covet 19 shots
there are multiple reasons for that but
the bottom line is that people have
legitimate questions
as to the safety and efficacy of these
of of many vaccines but especially the
this bill will establish a process that
gives doctors and other medical experts
ample opportunity to weigh in
they do not have that under the current
administrative rulemaking process
parents and other concerned citizens
likewise will have a voice
in the legislative process
in these very important decisions
the decision to force a vaccination on
other citizens has very serious
implications that decision should not
rest on a single individual or a small
group
now i want to address a couple of issues
that came up we did receive testimony
from dhhs in writing which i'm i know
that we'll hear uh we'll hear shortly
um
one of the concerns there i think is an
implied statement that existing rules
existing administrative rules created
under this statute
141 c20
would essentially disappear
this bill was written with the
understanding and the assumption that
they would not
therefore
um i would
just like to put forward this idea that
i would be very open to an amendment
that would uh preserve the existing
administrative rules
until they expire and as as i understand
the last
renewal of the of the rules in question
were 2016 which means that the
legislature would have until 2026
um to to make a decision with respect to
the three vaccination requirements
the other the other concern that i've
heard expressed has to do with
imminent threats and the department's
ability to act quickly
in response to public health emergency
and i and i would bring up two points in
response to this the first is that
we have experienced and many would argue
are still experiencing a public health
emergency in the form of the covet 19
pandemic
that still has not resulted in
a vaccine mandate for school children in
new hampshire i am glad that it has not
and i think that the more we learn about
the uh potential side effects of of the
covet shots i think the wiser that
decision will prove to be
nevertheless
um
in what is
probably the the worst pandemic or the
worst public health emergency of our
lifetimes
some some people may have been around uh
with
excuse me when polio was uh
was was emerging
but really this is for for most of us
the worst pandemic of our lifetimes
um there has not been a
an emergency call to mandate a vaccine
for school children and in fact even
house bill 1633 which this committee
heard recently uh which would mandate
the covet 19 vaccine for school children
even that acknowledges that that such a
mandate shouldn't go into effect until
after the vaccine receives full fda
approval and not emergency authorization
approval only
and then
you know the second point i would bring
up with respect to imminent threats
does have to do with the polio vaccine
the polio vaccine had some there were
some
very tragic problems with the polio
and and
as a result there was there was quite a
lot of hesitancy around that
having said that the polio vaccine is i
believe a modern miracle
it has saved people from
um
from disability and and death
many many people and polio has been
declared eradicated in in the united
states as a result
the polio vaccine took seven years
to reach 80
vaccination rate seven years
so
here we are looking at um you know the
potential need to add a vaccine to the
to the
required schedule of immunizations for
children
and given the examples i've just
provided it it seems a stretch to me
that we could not do that through the
legislative process and that if we did
do it through the legislative process we
we couldn't
if it truly were an emergency that we
could not handle it as such and call an
emergency session
mr chairman that ends my my testimony
and i'll be happy to take any questions
if you like the chair has a question
i have heard from some people
why would you want the decision to be
made by lawmakers who don't know
anything about medicine
would you agree with my
comeback
which is
i'm willing to bet this bill comes to
this committee
where we have a good number of people
who are well trained in medicine and
secondly there'll be more wishing to
testify would you agree with that as a
good comeback
uh yes thank you mr chairman um
interestingly
uh the the the one person who
does have the power to create a mandate
under current statute does not
necessarily need to be a medical
professional in fact we have had
commissioners of health and the current
one is by the way but we have had
commissioners of health and human
services in the past who are not medical
professionals
um
i i would argue that there is
you know there is first the question of
medical expertise and i do believe that
if we have an open and transparent
process which involves hearings like
this then we have ample opportunity to
gather that information
the the the other side of the equation
is that by making that an open and
transparent process made by the people's
elected representatives we are really
opening the door to much broader
participation in the process which i
think makes for better decisions
thank you thank you mr chairman also
thank you for taking my represent taking
my question representative
um
in dealing with rulemaking
having been on the board for several
years
it's a long process it takes a lot of
public input
it's not something which is done in a
vacuum it does go through a legislative
process it has to go through the joint
legislative committee on administrative
roles which is gelcar
so there is an opportunity for the
public to weigh in on what rules are
so i would say that there is legislative
oversight
we also have the department of health
human services has an oversight
committee itself
so in essence we do have the ability for
the public to
thank you representatives so um
let me begin by saying it the fact that
it's a long process i will i will add
that to my points regarding the
ability to act quickly and uh the fact
that we can do that just as well um as a
legislature
so while it is my understanding that
there there is a a public input process
it is also my understanding that
objection to
administrative rule
by a majority of the committee is
required to to stop administer an
administrative rule from taking effect
and that
essentially the the
you know the valid reason to object to a
rule must be statutory and so i think
that there are um
there are potentially grounds for for
concerns to be raised and for the admin
proposed administrative rule to be
withdrawn based on those concerns
it nevertheless still puts the the
decision ultimately in the hands of one
person
and i i also believe that there is
considerably more attention for better
or for worse there is considerably more
public attention paid and press
attention paid to
the legislative process than there is to
the administrative rulemaking process
and for those reasons i think it's a
better if this is something better
handled through the legislature
representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
this is really a request for a
clarification
so i think that you said that
since the current rules don't expire
until 2026 that the
that the specific vaccinations that have
been added through the rules process
would
continue to be in effect until 2026
thank you my intention was that they
would remain in effect until 2026. i
believe that in order to accomplish that
and put everybody at ease as to
the the
the fact that those
remain in place would require an
amendment to this bill
representative
thank you um
given the fact that the legislative
process is
slow by design and is indeed still
slower than rule making rather
significantly
would you not agree well actually i
should say and also that the
a public health response in an emergency
has to be nimble and
quite quick
wouldn't you agree that this would
really tie the hands of our public
health experts in terms of dealing with
an outbreak let's say we had something
like the um
the flu outbreak of 1918 that really
severely affected young people and was
highly transmissible
and they would not be able to act in a
nimble fashion to deal with requiring a
vaccine for that you mentioned a special
session but
would that be wise to hold in the middle
of a pandemic to bring everybody
together
thank you for your question i i think uh
first of all we we do have ways and have
employed ways of
uh social distancing
that i think have that have addressed
the ability for the legislature to
convene
during a state of emergency
if
if the legislature
chose to do so i believe the legislature
could meet long enough to amend rules uh
to make other
other arrangements to to meet
um but i guess you know the the big
question here really comes down to risk
versus speed
um i think the the reason that the
current
the current covid vaccinations have been
authorized under emergency use is
because there was a sense of urgency
around getting them to market
having said that
there are also significant concerns
about them
and i think that many of those concerns
arise from the fact that they were
brought to market so very quickly
um so i i would i would call out risk
versus speed i would also say that
um the vast majority there there are
quite a few vaccinations that are
that
that people take voluntarily
if you look at the
the the number of well i can i can speak
in dollar terms
about 30 million dollars
of expenditure
comes from dhhs on vaccines
every
year
and of that approximately three quarters
of that dollar expenditure is for
vaccinations that are voluntary um so
things like the gardasil vaccine
um so
i i think in in in furthermore i think
that even if you look at the covet
vaccine you're seeing fairly high
vaccination rates
that are voluntary
yet there there is a significant portion
of the population um that has chosen not
to to take those vaccines so to me it it
ultimately comes down to you know if it
is really that much of an emergency that
we
that voluntary vaccination isn't enough
and we have to mandate it we have to
mandate it very very quickly and we feel
that the risk reward
is uh
is sufficient
we ought to be able to get together as a
uh just you you mentioned that the
covert 19 vaccine vaccination has not
been required by the dhhs
under this rule at this point in time
wouldn't that speak to the fact that
this rule seems to actually be working
then quite well
um
i should say the statute is working
quite well
i would say that it it
speaks to
the fact that dhhs has taken a very
judicious approach towards this one
um so
i
i always like to look at future
scenarios what might it look like under
a different commissioner or a different
set of people who are
running dhhs
i think the concern that people have and
again this arises largely from the the
kovitz situation and the fact that there
are mandates looming for a lot of people
um is
should we take a fresh look at the
process whether it has already broken or
not
should we take a look at the process and
say this ought to look different if
different than it does let's not wait
for a problem to come up
my hand was up
about clarifying the effect of
repealing in line six the rule
rule-making authority because once you
repeal the rule-making authority there
is no rule
there is no authority to continue the
rules so
i i agree that representative cofoult
has
so would you believe that i agree with
representative cofoult that
an amendment would be necessary in order
to continue those which i think we all
agree ought to happen
um
it was it was more a clarification
i'm sorry it should have been a question
it was more a clarification of the the
process and what happens to rules when
the authority goes away
so thank you thank you for your
clarifying question
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for these uh
this is the first time i've had one of
these things where the red light
actually came on it's valentine's day
my
i have
served probably under it in the
legislature
with at least six different
commissioners and you're right they're
all different
the
understanding i've always had
is that the commissioner
seeks advice from
those individuals there's no
commissioner in the world
that can be trained in all of the
aspects of that huge department
so that the
department has extremely well qualified
people
not the least of which is a medical
director
and also an epidemiologist i can't leave
that out
that is available
if you've
noticed that the governor does speak
often with the commissioner and the
epidemiologist on health matters
so that i'm convinced that
the commissioner does consult but if it
would make it better we could actually
say
the commission to shall adopt the rules
in consultation with appropriate staff
members
would you care to respond to the
gentleman's question
thank you representative thank you mr
chairman
i have no doubt that the commissioner
would
consult experts
and professionals within the department
uh in in making such a decision
uh nevertheless i i do believe that um
the the discussion the debate
the ability to
to sort of put all the the information
on the table before the public
is best served by a full legislative
process
representative gay
thank you mr thank you mr chairman
i have a couple of questions so i'll
just ask them all and you
answer what you want
okay
what do the administrative rules cover
if we keep the current rules i'm
assuming i'm assuming that the rules
mean the list of required uh
immunizations
not the current process of the
commissioner making the decision
um
so it's
yeah i'm guessing that that's
what it is that it's the list of shots
we would keep if we put the uh if we
make the amendment that obviously
needs to we need to in order to say that
representative gay i'm going to let him
answer your first question so we don't
forget what it is
uh thank you uh mr chairman thank you
representative for the question
um so the the administration
administrative rule um currently there
are the three
additional vaccines
those are varicella or chickenpox
hib and hepatitis b
the administrative rules also
specify the schedule for which
the the vaccines named in statute
are to be administered so um
so things like you know mmr
which which covers several of the
diseases
named in statute um are are called out
specifically so that you know mmr
it's two day two doses uh the first
administered on or after the first
birthday for grades k through 12. so
these are the and i'm actually not i'm
reading from a dhh document it's not the
rules itself but
um this kind of schedule is laid out and
that's based on
um the cdc schedule for these
vaccinations
which is also sort of reviewed and
approved by a wide variety of
of um
professional bodies including asip which
is the
um i forget what asip stands for but
it's essentially it's a it's a
nationwide body that that recommends a
certain schedule of vaccines new
hampshire only actually includes a
subset of those we don't include all of
them
um but but that's what's an
administrative rule
your second question representative
okay
we were on the question of time and
efficacy of time
doesn't it take a while to create
medicines and vaccines so the question
about that the legislature
would slow things down
wouldn't you say that the
legislature is not really going to be
slower if we need to do something
wouldn't you say that the legislature
would have enough time while new
vaccines or new treatments are being
developed
so that would
nullify the argument that passing this
would
and the legislature
when pressed can get things through
if everybody's of like mind
i'm leaving out one more question
should i wait
yes um so thank you again for the
question um so
yes i i think the the time it takes to
develop
a vaccine uh which was
done in record time for for covet 19.
then the amount of time it takes to do
some level of testing
which
happened in this case as well enough
that they could do emergency
authorization usage
um
but then the the additional time it
takes to to get to
uh that full approval full fda approval
without the emergency use
um
asterisk next to it all of that takes
time and i think that the the
legislature if it
i think the legislature is equipped to
weigh
the
the severity of the threat
the risks versus the benefits
of requiring a vaccine
and
voluntary rates of vaccination
up to that point to determine whether or
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative
would you believe that in 2018 a
hormonal contraceptive standing order
bill was passed by the legislature and
in that bill there were
directions for the department to set
administrative rules as to how that
would
work and that those rules are still not
finalized now in 2022 so
the administrative rules process is not
necessarily faster than the legislative
uh thank you representative yes i'm
familiar with the bill um i am i was not
aware of the uh of the fact that
legislative i'm sorry that
administrative rules had not yet been
finalized as authorized under that bill
um i suspect that uh that the process
um can take
longer or shorter periods of time
depending on the the urgency of the
matter
oh is there anything preventing
the commissioner
in a state of emergency of
adding a requirement of suspending
statute and adding a requirement
thank you for the question i'm afraid i
don't know the answer to that so i'll i
will defer to some of the experts who
are going to be up here testifying after
me
seeing none representative merchant
thank you mr chair thank you
you brought up a good point about the
administrative rules it is more towards
the statutory authority whether the
agency has the authority not how they
use that authority
so in saying that i do hear the concern
about having some legislative oversight
would it be possible at that point in
time we do have a legislative oversight
for the department health human services
the oversight committee which is
comprised of
representatives senators and so forth
along with skilled knowledgeable people
on that advisory would you be willing to
consent to or consider
that the commissioner can only bring
forward the rules with the consent of
that
oversight committee
it's sort of i'm trying to find a way to
thread the needle here between
no legislative oversight because that's
what rules create versus having some way
to go through a legislative process that
does grant them the authority to create
do you wish to respond um
so
thank you for the question
representative i i guess i would simply
say that i think that it is important i
i know each of us represents
the people in our towns and our
surrounding towns
and because the participation in gel car
and that the dhhs oversight committee
is limited to just a few representatives
i believe it's very important that every
citizen in new hampshire have an
opportunity to be representative be
represented as part of the full
legislative process
thank you and would you believe that
there is greater
uh
representation from the legislature on
jalcar
it's a larger committee than than there
are on the health and human services
oversight committee currently
it's a much smaller body
made smaller
yet
a couple of years ago and made larger
again
yes i would believe that
representative gay
thank you mr chairman
but my third question
is
if i can make it into a question
do you think do you think that opening
the discussion
for considering new
new guidelines
is much more extensive when it's open to
the public
than when
it's just restricted to
a couple of committees
especially considering
what has happened in the past couple of
years
when many of us had no ability to add to
thank you representative yes i i think
the the openness of the discussion the
the opportunity for dialogue and and
input is
an important element
uh in my mind the most important element
is the representative process that is
that everybody have a voice in that
but i think you bring up a good point
and it is um that
as i said before i think the
the legislative process gets quite a
good deal more attention and
participation and
press coverage
then
than the rulemaking process
or
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question um as we're
discussing this it brings to mind the
hearings that that were going to be held
and then were cancelled um at department
of health and human services for one of
the rule making
i appreciate that it's a bit of a
balancing act to try and hear
everybody's voices but i'm wondering if
you believe that our established process
to hear the people's voices here in the
legislature is actually a better fit
than having a representative's hall size
crowd
trying to come to hearings about rules
at the department of health and human
services
thank you representative i
one of the great things about new
hampshire is that we do have such an
open process where anybody can come in
and testify and the committee
gives them time to express their
again i think what you're saying does
speak to the fact that the legislative
process
tends to be far more participatory
than
the rule-making process or the oversight
process
any other questions for the
representative representative acton
thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
my question is related to um the
rationale for for this legislation
i personally have
a very high degree of confidence in the
leadership of health and human services
department
my confidence
collapses when we start talking about
the federal
level agencies
would this bill give us
the ability to protect
the people of new hampshire from and out
of control or a power abusing federal
thank you for the question
representative i i don't i don't know
that it would i
i haven't really thought about how this
would
interact with federal uh mandates or or
federal law
um
you know even as it stands right now i
mentioned earlier asip which you know in
the cdc um
so the cdc essentially asip is one of
the organizations that is consulted as
in in coming up with the schedule
and um and new hampshire has not adopted
that full schedule so
i think that new hampshire has acted
judiciously and
um has really focused on
um on on a limited subset that they
truly believe are important for our
children our citizens
um i the short answer is no i don't
think that it will
have any
give us any any
leverage or power to push back on
federal uh mandates um so even the cdc
guidelines are sort of
we're accepting the cdc guidelines for
this schedule
for the vaccines that new hampshire has
chosen to make mandatory
thank you representative for your
testimony in introducing your bill
the cheer now calls on from dhhs abby
thanks good morning chairman pearson and
members of the committee
my name is abby rogers i'm the
legislative liaison for the division of
public health services and i'm joined
today by anne marie mccary immunization
section chief for the department
i wanted to thank representative cofoult
for his introduction of the bill it
provided some clarification on the
intent
other than what we were we read through
reading the legislation we are opposed
to the bill today and after the
introduction and the subsequent
discussion are concerned
about retaining our authority uh through
141c 20a to decide what vaccinations
are in statute and uh
and also to maintain our current
rulemaking authority
um and with that i'll turn it over to
good morning chairman pearson and
members of the committee i'm ann marie
mccary i'm the immunization section
chief for the department of health and
human services public health
um so thank you very much
for the comments and everything this
morning
the department does strongly oppose hb
1379 as it would undermine the the
protection of children from vaccine
preventable diseases
we do currently experience high rates of
vaccination largely because of our
school immunization requirements and the
commissioner's authority to adopt
these new vaccine requirements is
deemed to be critical and essential
we do have concerns about
as it is written it would remove those
other diseases which require vaccination
under administrative rule hep 301
including hepatitis b varicella and
hemophilus influenza type b
these vaccines
these diseases are not benign
we need to really remember about what
was happening before these vaccines were
in effect
before hib was available
and widely used approximately 20 000 u.s
children received
exposure
to this bacteria and it's a large and
leading cause of bacterial meningitis
for children that are less than five
years of age
for those children that did
become infected
there was a one in 20 chance that they
would die and of those survivors 10 to
30 percent of those children
had experienced permanent brain damage
so we really do want to remember that
these
diseases are not benign
so when we do
bring the vaccines into the state for
offering we do need to remember that
there are many processes that are taken
in taking place
first off before the new hampshire
immunization program adopts a vaccine
under the vaccine for children program
there is a vaccine selection committee
that takes place within the department
that would include input from providers
from epidemiologists and from experts
to really look at the vaccine safety
effectiveness before new hampshire even
decides to bring in the vaccine into the
state
and then there is subsequent
the administrative rules process that is
followed before making that school
immunization requirement
as noted there are 16
vaccines that are recommended by acip
the
advisory committee on immunization
practices
only 10 of those are required in new
hampshire new hampshire historically has
been a very slow adopter of school
immunization requirements
there are many states that offer other
vaccines that have been in existence for
quite a long time that new hampshire has
chosen not to go ahead and make school
requirements so there is very careful
consideration before making that
determination it is a so slow process
that is done very carefully
within the department and under the
commissioner's authority
for instance
historically speaking the hepatitis b
vaccine that was fda approved in
1881 and adopted in 1996 for varicella
that was
fda approved in 1995 and approved as a
school vaccination requirement in 2003
so historically there have been years
the department is very clear about there
is no intention to require covid19
vaccination
for immunization for child care or state
at this time given what we know about
the vaccine and given what we know about
the effects of
of co on children
it's also important for the commissioner
to retain this authority not necessarily
for the new vaccines that are coming out
but for the ones that are in effect when
we look at
for instance meningitis vaccination
new hampshire is
the only state within new england that
does not require this vaccine
and we would want to be able to move
quickly to make that recommendation
should say rates of meningitis were to
increase and that's just an example
about us
really wanting to protect that authority
to be able to be nimble it's not
necessarily for covid but there are many
other diseases that may emerge at higher
rates within new hampshire that we want
and in conclusion i think that we just
need to recognize that we oppose 1379
the existing statute and corresponding
administrative rules do provide public
health protection it also appropriately
balances the individual and parental
choice
there are religious and medical
exemptions to all vaccinations
the process also takes in that
legislative input
and the goal of keeping the children
enrolled in schools while protecting the
health of the children
should this bill be adopted there would
be serious concerns about children who
are immunocompromised
and there would be
decisions on parents as to whether they
could send their child to daycare or to
school so this is very
concerning for us
thank you
chair has a question i believe i heard
you say that the national organization
would you tell me what that is again i
is it asip it's known as asip acip it's
the advisory committee on immunization
practices and you said they have 16 they
recommend that is correct and we're
doing 10 of them
where does that place us in
the 50 states territ and other
territories and so on
uh yeah somewhere somewhere in the
middle and i can forward the committee
maps of
other vaccines that new hampshire does
not mandate that other states do
this one for meningitis is very very
impressive
the dark
are the areas that
require vaccination and the white is
where it is not required and as you can
see new hampshire is really an outlier
so i will be happy to pass that and
share that so we're standing in sync
with oregon washington and california
wow
that is correct and and out of sync with
texas
okay
i just did a quick scan on the map and
i'm trying to overlay blue and blue and
red states and
it doesn't overlay
very well
this is public health this is not a
political agenda
okay protect our children
many but i'll try and stick to the bill
so am i am i right in understanding that
maybe the reason for not adopting
meningitis is that we have a relatively
low incidence of meningitis
that is correct we have not made it as a
school requirement
some colleges universities do require it
if they are publicly funded
so it is really we're leaving it to the
discretion
of the university systems where we do
not have the oversight of that
the incidence in new hampshire has not
risen to a level that we would
entertain this at this moment in time
but as we know that the
things things change
that there's sometimes incidents of
disease that rise
follow-up
well it's just a whole other question
but i'll do two and then i'll wave off
is there
if
this
adopted
would it be better
to
have an amendment extending
[Music]
vaccinations that have already been
approved
until 2026
or would it be better to simply amend
this bill
to include the three approved vaccines
that have been added by rulemaking
in the opinion of the department the
department feels as though the authority
under rulemaking would be better um
under
the acip recommendations sometimes we do
have schedule changes so there is
changing of doses there's changing of
timing of doses
that schedule is outlined under the
administrative rules so as if statute
were the only place that we would have
that input we would not be able to um go
so it's not just the adoption of a
particular vaccine that is the issue
going forward it would also be changing
dosing and scheduling
as new information comes forward is that
correct that's my understanding yes
thank you
thank you mr chair nils thank you for
what i heard earlier was that there's
been a slow adoption of some of the
vaccines
i think
not sure exactly which vaccine was
referred to but it was a a lag time in
there
and what i'm trying to get back to
looking at the administrative rules
when were the last adopted or changed
in order to include a new vaccine
and that was for varicella
which
has the varicella vaccine has prevented
more than 3.5 million cases of
chickenpox 9 000 hospitalizations and
hundreds of deaths each year
chickenpox we consider that as a rite of
passage for many of us
but we also have to realize that the
failing to prevent the check-in box also
means that individuals
who were infected have a greater chance
of shingles as adults
follow up
thank you mr chair
in adopting the rules for verizon in
was that something done through a long
process because i think it was on the
schedule before that quite some time
before the state actually adopted it so
i'm trying to get to is that the speed
in which we're acting at the
administrative level versus legislative
level
in some ways legislative is moving
faster than what the agencies going
through rule making process
thank you for your question i'm sorry i
don't have that information about the
time lag on that
representative kanark
yes i wanted to revisit the question
that representative weber made about
taking the three that are currently
under rules and just putting them in as
required vaccinations and you commented
about the need for being in rules
because the ability to set dosing
schedules and so on and so forth
but don't we already have that right for
all of the ones which are listed already
such as ethereum lumps pertussis that
under administrative rules you can
change those doses and so on as needed
anyway
and so
wondering wouldn't it be better if we
just got them into statute
to begin with and then you would have
the rules that would apply to that
rather than keeping them as a separate
sort of class of vaccinations
unless there were a reason you might
think you might drop that vaccination
then that would be a good reason
to keep them in rules but i was curious
thank you for the question
representative knurk um emory can speak
to the the programmatic programmatic
goals i i think that we would like to
retain our authority in roles it just
adds more flexibility for us um as emiry
said if if there's a dosing change we
would be able to address that there
if there was an occasion where we might
need to drop a
you know a requirement that we had put
in statute then that would be
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i'm concerned about the ability for the
members of the public to find when
there's going to be a hearing on
administrative rules
myself as a legislator i have had a very
difficult time finding that
and i i'm concerned that there would not
be public input from constituents who
otherwise would like to have input
because they are unaware that the
hearings are taking place
what um
could you
enlighten us on
how that can be
sure
thank you for the question
representative cushman when uh rules are
being processed and we have submitted a
rule to delcar there is a public hearing
that is posted on our website and i
believe is publicly noticed by gelcar as
well
so it's really i think that
the process is you if you're looking for
that rule you need to be able to to find
it on our website you can do that by
searching
um and that
information would be available through
the gel car sort of web page if you will
currently
follow up
please thank you mr chairman um
would you
be agreeable to some kind of amendment
to require that those rules also be
noticed in the legislative calendar
so that
the public can and legislators can be
made aware of it and find it easily
where they're normally looking for
legislative changes
uh
sure i think that that would be a
conversation for the policymakers to
have with gelcar to see how that would
be best better noticed
representative merchant
thank you mr chair and also thank you
for taking the question my understanding
is gel card does post
in the legislative calendar its meetings
and is also if you go to their website
it's a comment that i have to follow
you would believe that you would believe
that you would thank you very much
representative mckay
very trusting of us thank you
representative mckay thank you mr
chairman
um
this is a question around how the
commissioner operates and i
suspect you don't want to answer those
questions and maybe john williams would
but that
my understanding is when ols
deals with legislation
they always put in the commissioner will
do whatever it is
not
recognizing that the commissioner and
the department are synonymous
but that
in your experience
does the commissioner consult with
with the professionals that we're
discussing right now as a routine matter
in
uh making decisions because the
question has been raised about
the the training of a commissioner
and we know that there's no
training in the world
that could
train a commissioner to do everything
that that department does
so that i've always assumed
that
the commissioner consults and having
known the present commissioner for a
long time
it's my assumption that she does do that
can you comment about that without
any great fear
thank you for the question
representative k uh sure uh the
commissioner um has a medical director
uh dr jonathan ballard which is uh as
medical director of dhhs as well as dr
chan which is epidemiologist uh the
clinical the rules that you see um that
are written for the department related
to clinical issues and matters are
written by subject matter experts who
who are practitioners and physicians
and certainly there's broad consultation
with many stakeholders
and and clinicians before making any
important medical decisions that you
would certainly that a commissioner
would implement in the state
the chair has a question um
i find sometimes
a hearing
can serve as a safety valve
and that during a crisis
some people feel panicky
and sometimes therefore
their emotions
can build up
and to know that there's a possible
outlet for that a hearing a
contacting
one of us who is on oversight or
something like that
may not specifically add scientific
knowledge but it may give some
folks who are panicking and
understandably so a sense that their
voice is being heard and
i look at a number of the bills that our
committee and other committees have had
that seem to me to have that safety
valve value if nothing else
which leads to the question
given that
would you recommend some vehicle whereby
the
flexibility and integrity that the
department needs
and the
at least safety valveness
of the public's input could sometime be
brought together in a marvelous
conjoining
was a question in there i forgot where
could you think of something like that
would do that yes i mean i i i could we
certainly couldn't give that thought i
would
reference a bill that the committee
worked on last year hb 187 related to
the commissioner's
emergency powers and there were some
outlets in that bill i think that this
committee had worked on related to a
variety of issues including some some
additional oversight as representative
merchant mentioned the um ethics
oversight committee and such um that you
know certainly i could direct the
committee to to review that bill and see
if there may be some outlets in in that
legislation that was considered last
session
would you believe there was an item that
was totally misappropriately called a
housekeeping item
that is attempting to do just this
i would
soloway
thank you mr chairman and mr mccarry
nice to see you um i
rather than asking a series of follow-up
questions can i simply take you through
some inquiries and if you agree just nod
yes and then we'll get to the end and
you can not yes or no so
um
are you aware
of outbreaks of meningitis that have
occurred in new hampshire in the past
and is it common that these outbreaks
occur at colleges universities and high
schools
and is it possible
that meningitis or other communicable or
infectious diseases
given the
impending relaxation of quarantine rules
may in fact show up in unexpected
numbers
okay
do
we and do we therefore need to have
rapid rule making response to deal with
thank you very much that was great
testimony thank you thank you for your
question for the audio recording each of
the four questions that the honorable
gentleman asked
was answered with an affirmative nod
representative delemus
[Music]
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so
as i'm hearing all of this
i know meningitis has been around for a
long time um but do you believe that
there is if there's a rise in infections
that the legislature could not respond
in a nimble way are you are you saying
that that the legislature is
not
you can't trust the legislature to
move
quickly to help with these
with an arising situation
i i don't know
you know how you feel about us thank you
for the question uh representative
delemus i i don't think it's a matter of
trust certainly it's a matter of being
as you said
able to act quickly if there's an
outbreak of meningitis decisions need to
be made very quickly so people don't
lose their lives it's not that the
legislature wouldn't do everything they
could to meet but there could be um
delays that we would not want to um to
have due to the severity of any kind of
outbreak and it really would be
protective of public health to maybe to
consult with clinicians to make the
right decisions with without having that
extra step follow-up
thank you
thank you um
has there been a situation i i just
would like to know
uh give an anecdotal situation where
that has happened where you've had to
move quickly to make rules or change
rules
to date no
thank you would it be possible again i
love to square circles whenever possible
it's not always possible but sometimes
it is
for the department to be
authorized
in an extreme emergency where you got to
move fast
to move fast
for a 60-day period 90-day period
at which
time then the legislature we believe
will have had the opportunity to meet
to either say keep doing it or stop
doing it but you've got that ex
emergency response
ability
thank you for the question i i do
believe under rsa uh 21p if it is the
statute that has affects the
commissioner's emergency powers there
there is that ability um if the if this
if it's the will of the policy committee
to put a check on that and say you know
90 days after that decisions made that
there would be a check that would be up
to um the decision of the policy
committee
in an extreme emergency wouldn't those
powers also be vested in the governor
thank you for the question yes um that's
correct
and it is it not true that
although confronted with a fairly large
emergency the governor did not take that
step
in this last
in this last case right um there are
issuances of emergency orders to meet
that need right thank you
representative gay
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions
are you aware
that the many tv announcements on covid
that the governor and commissioner and
dr
chan
never mentioned preventive
bolstering of immunity like
encouraging people to take vitamin d3
and zinc and all these other things that
we've learned about recently
and then were you aware that the
commissioner actually banned the
treatment of covid with
topic months you for the question uh the
department agrees that the most
effective and safe way to protect
against coven 19 is uh the covet 19
vaccination
yes i would add um certainly when you
look at health holistically we do
believe that it's also true that people
should do anything they can to stay
healthy which is exercise get some you
know be out in the sun and take vitamins
and supplements to provide that but the
coven 19 vaccination is the best
tool against covet 19.
i believe that during the state of
emergency when you reference the
medication that was put on hold by the
commissioner i think that was due to a
shortage a perceived shortage that there
may be that drug is used for other
things and there were concerns that
there may be a shortage um i said i
think certainly that um going back to my
further reference back to hb 187 last
year i do believe if you review that
there is a provision that was added in
that bill to address the issue that you
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you
the chair calls
laura condon from bedford to come up and
she says she'd like to speak in support
good afternoon mr chairman
and
honorable committee members my name is
laura conde and i'm from bedford i'm a
volunteer new hampshire director of
advocacy with the national vaccine
information center we serve to educate
and inform and direct resources as
needed and requested we're an advocacy
organization i also serve for five years
as public member on the board of
directors of the new hampshire vaccine
association i support house bill 1379.
this is a bill that provides appropriate
needed balance i'm going to jump right
to a correction here
would you believe that the department of
health and human services already
mandates covet vaccines for children in
so i'm going to you know jump right to
that part so let me go through
my testimony here and that is
through the foster family rules that
were imposed on foster children
while the the there are public hearings
proposed on rules that rega the the the
process requires um
public hearings those hearings are
difficult to find as we've heard and
most people including legislators don't
know they have access to those
concurrence is the correct term as the
legislative committee jail car has no
authority to amend proposed rules and no
authority to deny the rules that the
commissioner has statutory authority to
impose
the public has historically been denied
the opportunity to express concerns or
support through the jail car meeting
even though statute provides them that
opportunity at the june 5th 2020 jail
car meeting at the foster family rules
there were 89 concerned parents on that
zoom call only one and that was me was
allowed to speak briefly and when i
question legislative authority to impose
these aggressive max vaccine mandates
that
are that require every cdc recommended
vaccines and that's where the coveted
mandate comes in
because the cdc now recommends covet
vaccines for adolescents and young
adults
without religious exemption i was cut
off and no one else was allowed to speak
so there are vaccine mandates and foster
families
for the covet vaccine and it's for
children in the foster family household
foster children biological children and
this is up to age 21.
so you should be aware that there
already are coveted vaccine mandates i
will remind you that you asked to speak
for three minutes and it's over the
lunch hour so i'm going to ask you to be
brief please okay
um
something as serious as vaccines require
a thorough review
and only the legislative process
provides that thorough review as i've
experienced for the jail car process
does not
as we've heard the commissioner need not
be a doctor in fact our current
commissioner is not a doctor she is a
nurse but the previous commissioner
prior to her was an attorney with no
medical background there was mention by
dhhs there's a vaccine selection
committee but in fact i made a 91a
request for information on the vaccine
selection committee in minutes of their
meetings and i was told there was no
records responsive to my request so
apparently that committee does not exist
the hepatitis b vaccine history shows
that there were no recorded cases of
hepatitis b in infants and babies in new
hampshire prior to imposing that vaccine
requirement so there's never been an
established need
for that vaccine on children to reduce
zero below zero
in fact hepatitis b is not a
communicable disease in a daycare
childhood setting and the fact of that
is emphasized by the fact that a daycare
worker or a teacher can be hepatitis b
positive and they could be in that
daycare and in that classroom but a
child who's not submitted to three doses
of that vaccine
could not that's not a benign vaccine
they've already been 65 reported deaths
of infants in new hampshire because of
the hepatitis b vaccines where
where shots are being rushed to market
and children are dying following these
shots the time is now for the
legislature to resume their authority
over vaccine requirements and to guard
against vaccine requirements that would
cause more harm than good for our
children and i please urge you to vote
as ought to pass on this very good bill
very and very needed bill
and i'm happy to take any questions
i did rush through
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman i don't i do not
have a question for
miss condon but i i wonder if we could
get some kind of clarification from the
people from
the hhs about the issue with foster
children being mandated i was about to
ask that question uh thank you um ms
condon you may step down
and i will briefly recall the people
from dhh if they wish to
respond
a number of
assertions were made and
i'd like to hear what the department
says
um thank you very much chairman pearson
members of committee and we are always
here as a resource to you to providing
information um
as far as our public health um piece of
this they were not involved specifically
i do have surface level knowledge that i
can get you more information on
my understanding is that as part of our
rule-making process and compliance with
federal law and federal mandates that
children are in foster care settings
under the federal scheme of things and
again i can follow up with attorney joe
ripson who's our director for division
children youth and families that we were
required to proceeding forward
with that as we
have to remember that foster care is a
voluntary process in other words we want
to encourage people to be part of that
process but it is a process that family
members who want to take in children or
individuals who want to take in children
do have to adhere to certain guidelines
including those that are required under
the federal law for the funding for
those programs so there was to my
knowledge based upon second-hand
information roles that were promulgated
within i believe the last year
that did address this issue there was a
compromise made and again i have to rely
upon those subject matter experts who
were there that there was a carve out
made for i believe households where the
foster kids were over six years of age
but i'm holding at that point because
i'm again working off of distant memory
of the subject matter and
given the scope of what the bill was
about today this is the best i can do to
try to respond to your question thank
you very much i'm going to ask that you
having heard some
statements that were made recently
you get back to this committee by email
and let us know
how you see it yes and what i'd like to
do is actually have the appropriate
resources in touch with this committee i
just did my very best just to give you a
very high level information but i would
um defer to those at the division for
children youth and families to be the
ones that respond to this committee
regarding the specific federal law and
the mandate around that and the reason
why they were required to proceeding in
that direction to requiring certain
immunizations within households for
foster care
who
for whom
no
i did
now um
no
we have a few cards that came in at the
last minute and let me just say that i
find that somewhat disingenuous
you've been here for a while you've
heard the hearing we try to plan the
hearing in certain ways
cards that suddenly appeared
you will get two minutes each and we
have a timer up here two minutes we have
found in previous hearings people can
really say what's on their heart and
mind within two minutes
with that the uh chair calls shauna
healy
what
thank you and i apologize there was a
pile of cards over there and that's
where i placed mine versus handing it to
someone so mine has been there since the
beginning
i am in support of this bill
as a mom of six
i have children with different
neurological
and physical issues i have a 15
fifteen-year-old son with autism
everything affects him differently than
my other children
medication supplements food vaccines
there is no one-size-fits-all for
children
three of my children are here with me
today they're homeschooled
because the last two years have
raised some concerns for me as a parent
they're very well behaved thank you so
much well
thank them they're doing very well i get
concerned
at dhhs making decisions for my children
when i hear them come up here and
there's a lot of fear in their facts
fear about diseases and
how
simply because we've been in a state of
lockdown for two years that certain
diseases are going to come and start
just being huge problems again
i just think the promotion of fear over
the last two years has
affected our children in such
huge ways
that
we're going to have generations of of
issues going forward
parents know what's best for their
children
and these vaccines are still in clinical
trials they should not be required to
attend school
and um
where there's risk there has to be
choice
one minute 34 seconds thank you so much
and if tony fallon
i don't know if you've noticed but this
microphone is like a doorknob now
so
i'm erin fallon i'm from wolfeboro falls
i
met all of you wonderful
representatives
uh i don't know six weeks ago
when we were talking about about
ivermectin and it was about religious
freedom it was about health care choices
and i'm back for the same reason
and i was here 10 years ago for lyme
disease for the same reason
lyme disease went for through the
legislature and gave
infected people more choices because it
went through the legislature
what representative colfax is proposing
is giving people healthier
educated choices and that's what i'm in
tony fallon also from wolfeboro falls
we aaron and i both spent 12 years as
adaptive sports volunteers skiing
particularly
we served primarily
autistic and other children on the
spectrum that were vaccine damage so in
general we're very cautious and with a
lot of
immediate
reasons for that and of course you know
mandates and dictates
really sounds like dictators i i so much
appreciate
representative cole fault bring this
forward because so much of what's going
on the last couple of years
it's just mandates made its mandates it
sounds like we're in a dictorial
situation
bringing us bring it back to the
legislature i think is vital
this vaccine is under emergency
authorization
it's experimental it's not effective
it's damaging
and there's no fault because it's under
emergency legislation as are a lot of
vaccines
another
kind of personal thing
january of last year we had an incoming
medical missionary
that we were going to host for 10 days
it turned into three months
he was vaccine damaged
after taking the second shot
it wound up with emergency surgery lots
of trips to doctors uh denial
that it was related to the vaccine by
hospitals
they said he was experiencing spousal
abuse he was single living with us so it
there are as this was mentioned by
representative gay there's other
responses besides vaccines
that are being hidden
and restricted
just as they were back with lyme disease
that that was such
it was a long course to get that passed
but when it passed it passed
overwhelmingly with both sides of the
aisle in a very divided time i don't
29 years i've worked out of the house
as a health advocate my wife has
d all the above lots and lots of health
challenges
if we went by one-size-fits-all all
she wouldn't be with us here we've gone
all over the country 30 seconds sir
individualized care for individuals is
so vital
and having a broad spec spectrum of
choices
to choose from is vital as well
uh the last thing in closing
i'm an architect i think that the dna
that god did is pretty good
i i also have a lot of caution with the
nature of some of these so-called
vaccines which rely on vaccines are
playing with their dna
i think god did the dna right
thank you and thank you so much for you
and your wife's compassionate
thank you community chair thank you
committee members um i just want to say
the one thing that i love about this
bill
is that it
helps break through that level of trust
we lack trust we lack trust in our
government we lack trust in in our our
committee members and all this type of
stuff this bill gives us trust and
transparency and that's something that
needs to happen more than anything else
to pull us back together as a state
that's it
thank you so much and the the last one
we will hear from today is ken ering
good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity i'd just like to be on the
record that i submitted that card before
representative cole fault spoke yes you
did sir i've asked for five minutes and
i hope that you'll honor that because i
will give you three well you know i
appreciate it and you're using them up
now so go
i believe that
people
have a right to be heard by their
representatives and if you would like me
to come back after lunch i would be
happy to wait but i believe i have an
opportunity to speak and express my
concerns i took time out of my day as
well to come up here to express my
concerns about this bill
so i will respect whatever decision you
make but i'm on the record as saying you
really should listen to the people when
they come up here
dhhs has said that that their position
is that covert 19 vaccination
vaccinations are the best protection
against
the covet vaccine
the ceo of pfizer has said that there's
little to no effectiveness of their
vaccine
people who have been vaccinated get get
the virus
and they transmit the virus so that's a
red flag for me
this committee listened to dr paul
merrick for hb 1022. that man came up
and he has professional
real-life real world experience that
ivermecton and hqc are prophylactics for
covid there's no reason
to have any bureaucrat be in a position
where they
can turn around and mandate against the
will of any parent that their children
be injected with an experimental vaccine
dr robert malone who is the inventor the
scientist who came up with the mrna
technology
that is used to create
and produce
the modern
and the pfizer vaccines
has warned
that these vaccines are very dangerous
for children
i send everyone in this committee a link
to a video it's four minutes and 32
seconds i urge you to watch that video
he warns of irreparable harm to children
potential irreparable harm
to their vital organs
their kidneys their livers their hearts
their brains their immune systems their
reproductive systems
and once that harm is done you can't
repair
the damage to any of those organs
there are safe treatments
that are available
dr merrick came here and testified to
that he did an awesome job
you hear the you hear the saying follow
the science you had scientists here you
have the ability to listen to them the
people who invented the technology
this needs to be apparent parental
decision they have to be involved you
have dhs has came up here and said they
need to retain their ability
to
make decisions about the vaccines
it's my understanding this is only about
the covet vaccine there are alternatives
to that you should not and cannot and
must not force a bureaucrat's decision
on a parent when there are safe
effective and inexpensive
treatments for their children
i'll just sum this up by saying this has
become a political issue we need to have
checks and balances you all are
accountable to the people
that's why you're here that's why you
need to make this decision i'm cutting
off my testimony short and respect to
this committee i have a lot more to say
but please watch that video i emailed
you
thank you for your testimony and thank
you so much to the dozens upon dozens of
people who have emailed us
and i know i read them and i know most
of you maybe all of you on the committee
read those testimonies
and
this is very very helpful to us and we
are there people who would like to work
with representative cofoult
as an amendment is under consideration
i see
merchants
and i see woods
and i see gay
okay if the four of you then can work on
some of the things and not them no
you have a question for me okay
um
could the previous speaker email us his
testimony
yes he's already emailed us his video
which we promised to watch but also the
thank you
thank you very much um
this ends the don't go anywhere
committee this ends the hearing on house
bill
1379 representative schuett
has a present for us all if you would uh
let us know what we are being gifted
thank you
yes first i'd like to thank your
committee for um
voting ought to pass
on
house bill 1327
that was the bill putting
diabetes into the reasons for having a
service dog
and as she promised
stephanie shaheen has sent copies of her
book
ellen coach
unfortunately i only have 18 of them i
think some of the members of this
committee may have received them
previously so if you have one please
don't get one but has both ellie and
coach autograph them um
actually
there is
a simulated signature on the frontis
page
i don't think she autographed each one
individually okay well thank you so much
wow a valentine's day present
okay um i think i adjourned that hearing
we will come back about ten past one
actually
uh
you
open the hearing to house bill 1270
one limiting the authority of the
department of health and human services
to mandate vaccinations in relative to
quarantine costs the chair recognizes
the prime sponsor representative
contoir
thank you mr chair and thank you
honourable members of the committee um
for the record my name is barbara
comtois from barnstead
belknap seven
um i'm here today to introduce uh house
bill 1271
and the reason that this bill came about
not have one person dictate to the
entire populace of new hampshire
on a mandate
regarding their health in their body
i do believe that the
person
one person should not be
especially an unelected official
should not have that
authority by themselves
and that's pretty much what this bill
does it also uh takes away the burden of
quarantine and isolation of the cost of
the person that's being isolated if you
are told to isolate and quarantine for
six months or 26 years
which means you have a loss of income
that burden of care should not be placed
on you alone
and that should not be mandated by the
state
it's a very simple
bill very simple language but i'm open
for questions
she's been flown in a great expense
representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking this question
um
i'd like to be able to see you when i
talk to you
so i'm just trying to figure out exactly
if the commissioner
were to decide that it was necessary
that a vaccine were to be used i guess
in an emergency
this says that
the immunization requirement shall
require a two-thirds vote of the
legislature
would that be in
when would that happen would that be
like ahead of time or would that be
[Music]
you know there's an emergency the
commissioner says that the way to handle
the emergency is through vaccination and
the legislature would have to
what would be the mechanics of that of
how that would work
thank you representative for the
question i appreciate it uh so anytime
we roll out a mandate it takes time to
make that mandate to roll it out and in
that time that she's discussing there'd
be plenty of time to call in the
legislature for a meeting
representative
weber
at the beginning of the current pandemic
wasn't it true that the legislature
could not meet for a period of several
months
because there was no way that we could
figure out how to meet safely either
how to meet safely in person and
consistent with emergency orders and
also
how
at that point we did not have the
capability of meeting remotely or
virtually
and
and some people wouldn't agree to
meeting virtually so if in the event
that the legislature was not allowed was
not able to meet how would you address
the issue
thank you representative weber for the
question
first off we are elected officials and
we are bound by our position to
represent the people of new hampshire
and by due diligence to do our duty
and therefore i think no matter what we
have a duty to meet
in the safest way possible but it is our
duty to meet and make these decisions i
think that not meeting for
a while
was a disservice to the constituents of
any other questions for the
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question would you explain the
last sentence
i i don't i just don't understand it
uh what do you mean by that
it repeals the requirement that the
owner is responsible for the cost of
quarantine chicago and commodities
i have no idea what that means
thank you for the question
um it has been brought to my attention
that some of this language has been
changed uh last year in august up by hb
187 and the folks behind me i'm sure
will speak to that
but currently under existing law it was
the way that i read it and i am not a
lawyer by any means
was that if you
were forced to be isolated or
quarantined
all the costs of that quarantine and
isolation
were on you
excuse me
yes follow up sir i i guess the last two
were what is then what is meant by cargo
uh representative could i'm
looking at the language here and i'm not
seeing that in front of me so i i guess
yeah 1271. it says the bill also repeals
the requirement that the owner is
responsible for the cost of quarantine
for cargo and commodities
what line are you on
it's in the analysis on the analysis oh
the intent was to make you well if you
have to
quarantine your cargo and your
commodities because the state requires
you to do so for an unlimited amount of
time
that is a that is uh a detrimental to
you as
a constituent
and
how do you
come back from that if that is your
business or your livelihood for um
thank you
thank you mr chair and also thank you
taking my question
right now the way i read this the
current law
an individual may refuse treatment or
immunization pursuant to
provisions are say rsa 41
c 15 6
which basically is pretty
self-explanatory so if the patient
already has the right to refuse
treatment
why do we have to have legislative body
given something that's already in the
statute
thank you for the question i believe
141c16 is new and when this was drafted
it was not
existing law
and i relied on ols
to tell me what to do
but
we still
should not have one person and an
unelected official mandating something
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman thank you for
letting me allowing me the follow-up
there's not really a man mandate they
can make the recommendation for
something to occur but ultimately still
comes down to the patient heaven the
ultimate say
not the commissioner so therefore i'm
still not sure why we need a law that
already says the patient has the right
of refusal
thank you for the question i do believe
um i haven't read 141
c-16 when i was drafting this bill is
being drafted so i really can't speak to
that
thank you mr chairman thank you for
i think the
concept of commissioner is confusing
because what what you are talking about
is a single person
has power to do such and such
my understanding of how the department
works
is that
if the commissioner represents the
department
the department
is like we've already heard today three
different people talking about the same
subject
the the commissioner is informed
by
very senior well-trained individuals
it's not the
my impression is it's not the
decision of a single person a
commissioner
and as i said earlier i've been at least
six or seven commissioners since i've
been here
and they're all different
and if we would have such a
state of confusion if that was a fact
but the fact is that every commissioner
i've known
goes to the highly specialized
staff
which is what i said exactly about an
i'd be interested in your response well
thank you for your question i appreciate
it um
you're right and i would think that most
commissioners
would look to a team of experts
but the fact remains they do not have to
and that lets alone that single
commissioner can make that decision
without
uh
seeking outside
advice or from her
peers
uh one single person can do it without
any of any any advice
follow-up
thank you mr chairman
what would you believe that
the oversight committee on health and
human services
has some responsibility
uh to counter what a
what what i would say would be an
inappropriate act by the
commissioner and
that the
the instead of the whole legislature
you've got the health and human services
oversight committee
which i understand if i remember right
meets
year-round it doesn't
follow the same procedure so there is an
established
structure there
that could deal with that kind of what i
would consider to be inappropriate
behavior
on the part of a commissioner
thank you for the question i'm not
familiar with that
commission
i'd be open to hearing
things but i do believe
that the way the statute reads right now
that the commissioner without any advice
from anybody can make a mandate
and i don't think that's appropriate
i can introduce you to the chairman of
oversight at some point representative
leon
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
for taking the question
i i'm reading through this and looking
at the reference and it says that an
individual may refuse treatment or
immunization pursuant to the provisions
of rsa 141 c 15 6.
but that
reads
when an individual subject to an order
for treatment by the commissioner
refuses to undergo such ordered
treatment the commissioner may issue a
complaint which shall be sworn before to
sworn to before a justice of the peace
such complaint shall set forth the
reasons for the order imposing treatment
the nature of the treatment to be
provided and the place or facility where
the treatment shall be provided upon
being presented with such an order any
law enforcement officer shall take such
individual into custody and transport
the individual to the place or facility
where the treatment is to be provided um
i'm thinking there may have been a wrong
statute because that does not sound like
could i have an inquiry of the chair an
inquiry of the chair takes precedence
thank you thank you mr chairman uh and
excuse me thank you for your forbearance
i was wondering we have also been told
by uh folks from dhhs that there is a
mistake in the drafting here
and i was wondering if it might be
[Music]
it's entirely up to you but if perhaps
the folks from dhhs could come and
explain to us what the issue is with the
statutes because i'm in the same
bewilderment as representative leon
and then we could have the proponent of
the bill back to explain
better what it what it is that she's
intending to do so that we have the
appropriate references in front of us is
that okay with you representative
congress yes it is because what they
have told me is the rsa 141c 15
6 has been stricken
with hb 187 and been replaced with 141
c16 and 141 20-c so yes there are some
affirmative nods going on behind you
so representative webber
and
not only do those references appear in
the in the bill as drafted but the
changes as far as i can tell are not
included
in the rsas that i'm linked to when i
get
uh when i when i go to the current what
ought to be the current rsas so
um any explanation that could be
provided would be really helpful so
we're all on the same page when we're
discussing okay
so the chair invites los tres amigos um
abby rogers anna marie mercury and john
chairman pearson and members of the
health human services and elderly
affairs committee for the record i'm
john williams the director of
legislative affairs and with me are
and marie mccary immunization section
chief
and i i'm here primarily just to walk
you through what is currently existing
in law and and what is not and then i
will turn it over to miss rogers and
also miss mccurry to
discuss the substance of their testimony
but i think at this point in time
procedurally we're up here only to
explain the bill has changed and then
miss rogers and also miss mccurry could
come up separately
to present on the department's position
that is my expectation thank you
so if i can draw your attention to the
bill on page one one page bill line
eight you'll see a reference to rsa 141
c15 roman 6.
that statute still does exist however it
does not exist as a cross-reference in
the provision of law that you see under
rsa 21p
53 roman 5.
last session this committee heard hb
which was
adopted and heard by the senate and
passed into law effective august of this
past year so as of august 11th of this
year
that citation now reads as follows
rsa 141
dash c colon 16. i'll repeat that rsa
141c
colon 16.
and that deals with mode of medical care
and then the second cross-reference
cites rsa 141 c colon 20
lowercase c again 141
dash c uppercase c colon 20
dash c which deals with childhood
the provisions that you see on the
repeal on line 9 relative to rsa 141 c
15 roman 5 is in fact existing in law
and represent leon i believe you read
into the record exactly what that
provision applies to it applies to
commodities and conveyances and not to
specific individuals but rather if you
look at that statute that it's repealing
it talks about business owners their
assentees and others who are owners of
conveyance and commodities so we're just
here to hopefully not create more
confusion but pointing out what
apparently was not drafted initially
representative folsom thank you chairman
thank you for taking this question would
the section on cargos and
commodities be better addressed by a
different committee that has to do with
commerce
yes i would have to agree that this
would seem to be a bill that would go
before the commerce and consumer affairs
committee in the house so it relates to
businesses and commerce so this transfer
will hunt then huh
okay thank you appreciate that
uh representative
canark
i'm still confused you commented that
um and now is that what is currently
when we go to the browse the statutes is
that what's currently correct in that or
is that not this right wording currently
so uh reference pearson it's interesting
that the laws that get passed it takes
approximately anywhere between four to
six months for them to actually catch up
to the rsa so many times when you're
thinking you're looking at existing law
until it actually is updated it you can
actually um not be looking at existing
law it's just a fact of life that we've
all lived with who've done legislative
work
so if you go online at least when i did
it about two days ago i saw the correct
citations that were as a result of house
bill 187
and if you see in the annotations on the
bottom you'll see a chapter law
reference and the year um it probably
even have the exact date of august 11
in the um section below showing you the
current date of that section of the bill
follow up please follow up well that's
what i'm on if we're talking about 141c
colon 16.
i've just pulled it up and it has 1986
1995 effective november 1 1995 and the
source below
nothing
very hard not to be confusing
this bill in front of you at least as in
terms of section one of the bill seeks
not to amend the cross reference that
has been deleted because that still does
exist in law
what it does is it amends rsa 21p53
roman 5.
roman 5 does not exist in the current
format that you see
before you so that's that the cross
references within that have been uh the
one citation on
line eight has been eliminated by virtue
of the legislation and replaced with the
two respective rsas that i'd mentioned
previously okay follow up again please
follow up so then to get that proper
language if i remember right if one goes
to the bill as it's been enrolled after
it's been passed and signed by the
governor the pre the expected new
language which hasn't gotten into the
website will be there so is is that 187
was that the bill that did it okay it
was house bill 187 again i went to the
uh revised statutes annotated that you
review online it shows the the correct
law the current law as reflected by
house bill 187 however when this bill
was drafted which would have been around
the lsi filing period in september i my
expectations are that the rsas weren't
updated at that point however typically
to defend the office of legislative
services because they do a good job they
cross reference against bills that have
recently passed recognizing you can't
rely upon the online rsas because
they're not going to show you those
changes until probably anywhere between
representative weber
so
am i right in thinking that now one of
those cross references is to 141 c colon
16 mode of treatment and care
which reads currently because that
hasn't been changed it's just the
reference to it that's been changed
nothing in this chapter shall be
construed to authorize the commissioner
to restrict in any manner a person's
right to select the mode of treatment of
his choice or to refuse treatment when
treatment is ordered by the commissioner
under rsa 141c15
which is where we came from
or to request any physical examination
or treatment of a person who in good
faith relies upon spiritual means or
prayers for healing
such reliance or treatment or refusal of
treatment shall not be considered a
danger or menace to others under any
provisions of this chapter
provided however that there is
compliance with the sanitary isolation
and quarantine laws and rules adopted
under this chapter this section shall
not be construed to prevent a parent or
guardian from exercising his legal
responsibilities
thank you that's much more helpful and
i'll look up the other one
forthwith this is
this is for the purpose of clarifying
you will come back later for content any
other clarification questions while
they're trying to leave representative
canark actually it just is an enormous
favor to the committee i think if you
could prepare a little document that
would that would sort of basically take
the text of this bill
with the pr well it shouldn't be that
bad but with the proper references and
then put in with the proper language is
because i am still
confused i'm still looking up this five
and i still see the language that is
currently there and it except for the
bold
and so i'm confused if you could sort of
like i know it sounds like a rewrite of
the bill but it would be just giving us
the proper references so we could
actually make sense out of it because i
am doubt that i'm the only one confused
in the room
so
i second that
chairman pearson again a careful
walk-through we're trying to keep it a
very high level
here as part of our written testimony on
the bill i understand from ms rogers
that we do have
the references in there
in terms of bearing ownership we are the
department health and services this is
not our bill respectfully and i do think
that the office of legislative services
to do a tremendously good job should be
the one who actually become responsible
for doing what you're asking us to do
since they originated the issue before
this committee we're just a messenger if
that's okay yeah but they're over there
and you do get to tell both of us what
thank you mr chair
representative knurk we're now on to
content or policy yes um
given i was looking at the issues in
line six
given that it's not real common that
this legislature agrees with a
two-thirds vote on a whole lot of issues
and our bar for putting in immunizations
of individuals normally is a majority
vote
why is it you require a two-thirds vote
in this particular case
thank you representative actually i had
thought about that and thought maybe a
three-fifths vote would be more uh
practical
but i don't think just
simple majority uh it is
the way to go
follow-up
but may i ask since it's normally
majority vote for all other
immunizations why is it uniquely
different in this case
thank you um
i don't believe we should do things
along party lines i think we should do
things
as
a whole because we are representing the
whole of new hampshire so therefore
a three-fifth vote two-thirds vote i
think would be
a better representation for the people
representative gay
thank you mr chairman um i have a couple
of questions
one of them is the nuts and bolts do you
envision
a legislative consideration of
immunizations
to be presented as a bill
thank you for the question um
no i think this would be
you know the commissioner
wanting to impose a mandate across the
state
and currently under that's one person
getting to decide everything for the
entire populace of the state
and an elected official at that
i don't think that that bodes well for
the people of the state and i think that
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and in light of
what we've just heard from the
department
there is a section that
is incorporated here
because it says an individual may refuse
treatment or immunization pursuant to
the provisions of rsa and it's the wrong
reference but what the r one of the
right references says
is
nothing
authorizes i'm paraphrasing
nothing authorizes the commissioner to
restrict
in any manner a person's right to select
the motive treatment
of his choice
or to refuse treatment when treatment is
ordered by the commissioner under
this statute
or to request any physical so so the
person can refuse
the person retains ultimate authority
over their body and they can't be
examined if they don't want to be
examined they can't be treated if they
and
that
if the person in good faith relies upon
spiritual or prayer me
for healing
they must be allowed to continue to do
that
and then it says such reliance or
treatment or refusal of treatment shall
not be considered a danger or menace to
others
provided that there's compliance with
so
and there's a further clarification that
the section shall not be construed to
prevent a parent or guardian from
exercising their legal authorities
so given all of those protections that
are already there in statute to protect
somebody from
being forced to accept something
that they don't want
an immunization requirement
of two-thirds of the legislature because
the authority in the individual to
refuse any of these things
as as as the decider of last resort the
commissioner doesn't actually ultimately
wouldn't you agree that under this
statute the commissioner doesn't get to
decide anything ultimately about what a
person puts in their body or refuses to
put in their body
thank you representative for that
regarding what you just read it would
appear that way but without having all
the legislation in front of the rsa in
front of me it's really hard for me to
make a hard and fast determination
however
what it does say also is that the
commissioner can still force you to be
quarantined and isolated and i do
believe there's also a section where
they can tell you where you have to be
isolated and quarantined at
and i think that would be
a cause for concern um if i you if it
didn't go into further detail
thank you thank you
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking another question um listening to
or reading through that section that was
just read out
when i'm hearing that it sounds like
that's only protection for those who
only rely on spiritual means or prayer
for healing so i'm worried that that
might only apply to only a very very few
narrowly defined and
um
and pretty granular uh sex so i'm
curious as to whether the intention was
to have that more broadly based and this
was more of a drafting issue or if
you're looking to simply lock into what
what is already there
uh thank you representative for the
question and yes
that point that you made up about the
religious exemption and like i said
without actually seeing the language in
front of me and reading through the
entire rsa to see how it all flows it's
really hard for me to make a
determination but as we're finding out
now
especially in my county with our nursing
homes there you know some folks are
applying for religious exemptions and
they're being denied so the question is
is what would be considered a religious
any other questions representative gay
do we have spell in the bill is there an
intent to spell out protection from
forced quarantines and the cost because
that's in the description
but i don't see anything that spells out
do we just simply wipe out
wipe out where it says
europe creek and that's your problem if
you're ordered
or is there really protection and we're
going to pay you back if we force you to
miss out
and lose lose property
lose business expenses lose income
thank you for the question
so at the time of drafting um
we weren't really looking at the
quarantine and the isolation issues on
this
um but we were looking at
how the state was imposing that you
incur all the cost
what am i saying the quarantine
of
your goods or your you know business
property or whatever whatever you need
to do to make a livelihood
anytime you do that
you're hurting the family unit which in
turn actually is a detriment to the
state
and the
government should not be forcing someone
to pay for something that they are
mandating
it would be an unfunded mandate
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
taking my question
so if
if i am highly contagious
therefore i have all the rights in the
world to walk around the city the way i
want somebody can't quarantine me
somebody can't put me in isolation is
that kind of the heart of this it's
basically saying that i can do as i want
when i want i don't have any
responsibility to my fellow citizens to
be sure that i'm being quarantined
thank you for the question
representative i would hope
that each and every person
and everyone here would take personal
responsibility for their actions
and i think that personal responsibility
is something that um we're losing sight
of
and and and what we're doing some of the
time
um and then i look at um i did some
research on typhoid mary
and what i find found out
that she was forced into isolation in
quarantine for 26 years of her life she
died alone with no friends no family no
nothing
because she was considered a threat to
society
representative would you suggest that
perhaps that was overreach
and that while she was contagious
quarantining even forced would be a wise
idea but now medical science would say
26 years is probably not
a good thing
thank you mr chair and yes i would say
that is definite overreach thank you
representative woods
thank you mr chair just for
clarification would you believe that
also typhoid mary was
knowingly and directly related for 53
deaths
thank you representative and yes i
understand it was
i thought at 51.53 yes
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman representative
just quickly are you also aware that
typhoid mary refused to stop cooking for
families and thus spreading typhoid
thank you representative salloway yes i
in doing my research
because she thought she was doing a
greater good she didn't realize the
extent of that
so
the chair again if that being the case
sometimes is it not right
that
well-educated people in medicine may
make a wiser decision than the
individual him or herself
thank you
representative for that
where it's it's a very fine line that
we're talking about
so
i don't think that people should go
around getting people sick but prior to
this
pandemic
people went to the grocery store all the
time coughing and sneezing and getting
people sick we didn't ask them to be
isolated we didn't ask them to be masked
we didn't ask them to stay home we would
hope that they would have done that
but
they didn't feel compelled to do so but
we didn't force them and that yet they
spread the germs and people did die from
the flu and influenza and pneumonia and
all of that from people uh being
contagious
but they still went about their daily
lives thank you representative merchant
thank you mr chairman if mike can go
back
i also like you take personal
responsibility very seriously
it's part of what i have is a
responsibility to myself but also most
more importantly to my fellow citizens
in society in order to have society work
but what do we do with individuals that
don't take that responsibility seriously
that basically say it's my rights not
yours and i'll do whatever i want and
therefore if i want to walk around with
a contagious disease i'm entitled to do
that what do we do with those people
thank you representative i do believe
that we have people walking around with
contagious diseases all the time this is
not anything new
i think it's been happening since the
representative gay
thank you mr chair last year
um
last year one of your bills
was did address this issue i wish i had
it in front of me it would take a while
to find it but we did have something in
there that made a difference between
somebody who was contagious
and somebody who was just being isolated
just in case
and it seemed like the wording was good
so would you like to
find that among the other changes that
are going to be
amendments that will be necessary
i'm open thank you representative gay
for for bringing that to the attention
um but yes um i believe um not my
particular bill but hb 220 was one that
any other questions for the
representative
saying none thank you representative
contoir
abby rogers anna marie mccurry and john
williams
good afternoon members of the committee
good afternoon chairman pearson the
members of the committee my name is anne
marie mccary i'm the immunization
section chief for the department of
health and human services division of
public
uh health anne marie starts her
testimony i i wanted to um have a point
of clarification for the committee on
something that i think it was
representative leon brought up about the
statute that's linked the new statute uh
rsa oh not the new statute but the new
the new statutory reference in the bill
rsa 144 141 c
um
sorry 16 i think it was um
the way that we read that and i just
wanted to if i could walk the committee
through that is a 141c colon 16 mode and
treatment of care nothing in this
chapter shall be construed to authorize
the commissioner to restrict in any
manner a person's right to select the
motive treatment of his choice or to
refuse treatment when treatment is
ordered by the commissioner under 141 c
colon 15
1. so so and then it goes on to talk
about the spiritual means of prayer for
healing so we we consider that statute
to cover every every person not just one
thank you
the department has serious concerns
about
house bill 1217
as it would undermine the commissioner's
ability to effectively respond during a
state of emergency in order to protect
new hampshire's citizen from a public
health emergency
because of the pandemic a state of
emergency was declared in new hampshire
for a 15-month period the impact of
covet 19 has been and is far-reaching
since the beginning of the pandemic more
than 284 thousand granite staters have
been infected with covid19 and
approximately
2280 new hampshire residents have died
in 2020 covet 19 became new hampshire's
third leading cause of death behind
heart disease and cancer
emergency orders were set in place in
order to rapidly allocate resources for
voluntary vaccination to protect against
covet 19
and approximately 790 000 new hampshire
individuals were vaccinated during this
time period
that no order for vaccination was made
under rsa 21-p colon 53 demonstrates the
cautious inconsideration that is taken
by the department when considering these
matters
passage of house bill 1271 would
prohibit the commissioner from acting in
the best
interest of public health
under existing law the commissioner has
the ability to act quickly during a
state of emergency
to rapidly address the imminent threats
of the health of new hampshire residents
it is essential that the department
retain this authority in oversight over
immunization requirements to prevent
communicable diseases during a state of
emergency
prior to taking any
steps and making any requirements
there's careful consideration
examining the key criteria including but
not limited to vaccine efficacy safety
severity of disease likelihood of
infection and method of transmission is
taken
decisions are not making light lightly
in this
case
thank you very much for your time i'd be
happy to answer any questions that you
so just to be absolutely clear am i
correct
in thinking that unless the governor has
already declared a state of emergency
the commissioner of dhhs has no
authority whatsoever to take any of
these measures is that correct
anything further for the department
representatives
uh representative pearson i just wanted
to add one point related to the bill
you know the department does have
concerns with if
say
an individual case of immunization a
person if that was brought before the
legislature there there could be serious
privacy concerns that would be brought
up and we wouldn't support that um due
to those concerns
thank you i see that point yeah
all right thank you so much and uh
this uh concludes the hearing on house
bill 1271 and
um i don't know what your pleasure is
representative contra if you wish to go
to ols
and have them rework it and bring it
back to us or whatever your pleasure is
thank you
for everyone in the committee please get
thank you for showing me your pen
representative delemus and a piece of
paper on which the pen will write
thank you for showing me the piece of
paper
we will meet tomorrow we're not done for
today but we will meet tomorrow
we will not meet next monday the 21st
it is president's day and the building
is closed
we will meet
on the 22nd tuesday
and putting that calendar together i
thought that finishes up our bills and
the ranking member assures me that is
true
you want me to repeat it or is that an
exclamation of delight
finishes the hearings but not the
executive
but yet we're not done you will have a
forced vacation
on monday and tuesday february 28th and
march 1st
we will meet on monday
the 7th of march
here in this room
for
executive session so if you're working
on amendments on this or that or the
other thing
um
we've got another one of those drop dead
dates
if needed
we will meet on march
8th tuesday
but the landlord has uh claimed this
room for that day so we'll have to let
you know where we will meet if indeed we
are meeting
so that's the schedule going forward
then we start this docido all over again
because bills will be crossing over to
us from the body that was started a
century after hours was
first speaker of the house was 1684
president of the senate was about a
hundred years later i rest my case so
that's the schedule
any questions on that representative
shapiro
yes thank you for
announcing our vacation can we welcome
can we assume that that week which would
be monday february 28th that as well as
the fact that there won't be committee
meetings that there will not be full
house sessions that is a question to
address to the speaker's office i fought
the battle for five years saying can we
not have a break and um
i'm old for five so you may we'll see if
i'm o for six so give them a call and
let us all know um if you would please
follow up into what representative
superior was asking about
do we know in march that we have any
dates or session dates
not yet no a lot of this has to do with
booking of venues
and they're trying to do the best they
can
and it's not easy so
the long answer that is and the short
answer is no we don't representative
folsom
can we start an email campaign
where we send the speaker
well okay that's uh that's a compromise
i was thinking of going by his house and
honking the horn but i think i i think
yours is probably better for my job
security
yes representative leon thank you mr
chairman um i had been looking at the
schedule and trying to figure things out
and since we are not i don't think we're
the second committee for anybody i was
wondering if we were going to be meeting
the 21st and 22nd week and i hope not i
have reservations of which month of
march
i have no idea yet okay
a lot of this you'd have to ask them
over at the enchanted forest okay thank
you
anybody else just a question
representative gay is the 28th and
thirty
representative this is a high up on the
list of my important things to consider
uh no sense doing an exact session
because the next is gonna the ones left
are gonna take a while so uh we will
just take a ten minute recess the next
hearing is house bill 1495 and we will
do that at 2 15. so
we could depending on how quick this
i open the hearing on house bill 1495
fn relative to vaccine mandates for
government contractors in the absence of
representative lanzara we have
representative
thank you members of the committee i am
introducing house bill
1495-fn
i'm representative harvey bolia from
belknap county district 4 representing
tilton and samerton
i will just read the
uh introduction given to me from
representative lanzera
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
on behalf of representative tom lamzera
prime sponsor this bill is an act
relative to vaccine mandates for
government contractors this bill
establishes a chapter of law prohibiting
employee vaccine requirements for
government contractors except for
medical providers when there is a direct
threat present a new chapter prohibition
on certain vaccine requirements
amend rsa by inserting after chapter 9 f
the following new chapter
9-g colon 1
the state of new hampshire and all of
its political subdivisions companies
contracting with or otherwise doing
business with or receiving public funds
from the state of new hampshire or any
of its political subdivisions are
prohibited from requiring any employee
to receive vaccine
or to possess an immunity passport
immunity pass or any other documentation
for certifying vaccination or immunity
status
the persons or entities
subject to this chapter are prohibited
from discriminating against employees
based on non-receipt of a vaccine or
failure to possess an immunity passport
immunity pass or any other documentation
for certifying
vaccination or immunity status
as you can read in your copy of house
bill 1495 the definitions relative to
entities immunities etc are defined in
this chapter
you don't have to be an anti
you don't have to be anti-vaccine to
oppose the ever expanding requirements
mandates and demands the majority of
persons who oppose these mandates have a
narrower point
and one that's clearly correct the
government should not have the power to
force you to make a private medical
decision that has little effect on
anyone else your vaccination status is
by and large your business
no government can guarantee that no
matter how desperately we want to
mandate vaccines that people will not
become ill hospitalized and or die
you should have
you shouldn't have to show an immune
immunization passport to participate in
social life attend public education earn
a living and support the economy or to
leave your home
we find house bill 1495 objective and
its implementation correctly scoped
thank you for your time
and
a
little note
about
through 26
page three
um
looks like that was a mistake and
it's going to be omitted
to my understanding i i don't think you
have the citation correctly
page three it will say three on the top
of the page
which looks like page four that's how
so
uh
so i just have these notes
uh lines 23 and it says perspective
repeal okay that is page three sorry
okay the following are appealed
and then um there's 24 25 26
and it looks like uh it says
deleting draft
um
let me see if there's i'm sorry i don't
that's about all i know about this and
thank you it's not just representatives
know who reforgets these things we are
what those lines are doing 25 26 and 27
is
having
part of the bill take place immediately
on passage and then
section two
which i need to go back and find
won't take effect until january 31st
2022 which is already passed so that
and the
23 and 24
repeal
emergency licensing procedures which i
think are not the subject of this bill
i
i can't take any um
i can't say for sure okay but it looks
like i'll keep digging thank you
representative leon thank you mr
chairman um
i i actually spoke with the prime
sponsor about this when i read through
and i asked about those prospective
repeal lines 23 and 24 and that
effective date
because i saw that had already taken
place that actually was already repealed
so that was um when when i spoke with
him he said it was a drafting error on
the part of ols and that removing on
page 3 lines 23 and 24
and then line 26
would
would you believe that yes would you
believe that thank you
she seems to say yes representative
connerk
thank you very much and thanks for
taking my question um
if we look at page three so same page
but up at lines nine through thirteen
it lays out some issues for medical
facilities for exemptions which talk
about antibody levels
and proof of immunity or positive
diagnostic tests
are you aware that those
issues conflict with the cms rules for
implementation of the cms vaccine
mandate which would
place us out of compliance and therefore
at risk for loss of medicare and
medicaid funding
that it
may make us out of compliance for the
cms mandate because that's not included
as exemptions in that are you aware of
that
and what are your thoughts considering
we would have to then backfill
starting with at least 200 million
dollars just for the medicaid funding of
i'm not sure what you mean by cns
may i follow up follow-up okay although
this is not a question would you believe
that there is a cms mandate for for
medical facilities who receive funding
from medicare and medicaid
that they have to have vaccination of
employees and they have exemptions for
religious
and for medical but they do not have it
for
antibody levels or positive diagnostic
tests that's not part of their rules
that have been promulgated for that
of course that was not an effect when
this was drafted of course i mean i
appreciate that so
but are you aware that at this point in
nope no no i am not representative uh
chair speaking here with the question uh
same page same section lines 10 and 11.
somebody who has previously contracted
the illness
and therefore
is immune would you believe that the
medical practices that i oversee
have told me that they have had people
who
have
contracted the illness
and they are in fact not immune because
they got it a second time
so that the words in this line are
incorrect factually would you believe
[Music]
thank you for the comment i will have to
do you wish to respond
i'm sorry i thought i did i i said i
would take a look at that
passage i'm not um you're not the prime
sponsor i am not
i have trouble when i am so i have great
sympathy for you representative soloway
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question uh
on page one there is discussion of
direct threat but i don't believe that
it specifies who it is that will assess
whether an individual uh represents a
direct threat
what line
for director what line please oh i'm
sorry beginning on uh
page uh line 21 on page one okay it
describes direct threat and at the
bottom of that page line 28 it describes
the uh
factors which go into assessing a direct
threat but it doesn't say who will make
uh thank you representative soloway i'm
merely introducing the bill
and uh signing in uh support but not a
yes
thank you representatives um shapiro
sponsored
thank you mr chairman and um
thank you representative for taking my
question and i realize that you're
doing the best you can at the last
moments here but
um if i'm understanding this bill
correctly which i may not be
um if we look at
page one
line five six and seven
it seems to me that it is saying that
the state of new hampshire and all of
its political subdivisions and companies
contracting with or otherwise doing
business with the state would not not
would basically not be allowed to
require a vaccine
so isn't this telling private businesses
that they cannot take steps
to
thank you for the question
and the question is isn't this
telling private businesses that they
cannot take
it it is a statement as it stands um
and if if
represent if members of the committee
want to draw inferences about
motivations i i'm not prepared to
address that it just simply states
that the state of new hampshire and all
the political subdivisions companies
contracting with or otherwise doing
business with or receiving public funds
from the state of new hampshire or any
of its public div subdivisions are
prohibited from requiring
any employee to receive
a
vaccine or to possess an immunity
would you believe that i was just
reading through information that was
sent from the business and industry
association the bia and this is um
one of their legislative priorities is
not to have businesses um
prevented from
creating safety protocols um
their own safety protocols they're
against government mandates
are also against the government
mandating that private businesses cannot
do what they need to do to keep their
businesses safe and that's one of their
major priorities
i guess the question was would you
thank you i i would believe that i am
familiar with uh
the opinions of the bia over the last
couple years and i completely believe
that they would
make such a statement
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
taking the questions so follow up on
representative superiors
um different twist to it
many of our
contractors are out of state
um they also have to live up to their
state laws in which they're embedded
which they're
domiciled
that's one question it's part of it too
because sometimes even federal contracts
that many of the contractors work under
the federal government has restrictions
on how those funds can be utilized
so
doesn't this kind of impinge upon
the ability for a business to run their
business based upon the state in which
the domiciled also based upon the
conflict between
this state law and the federal law
which could preclude them from using
federal grants and federal dollars which
we would need for projects
because they couldn't comply with the
state law at the same time with the
yes right brazilian i would believe that
any other representatives
wishing to ask a question
okay seeing none thank you for being so
brave
thank you very much you can be our
valentine
i'll
thank you in your mind
that that was not the royal chairman's
representative excuse me hi
miz
paula minihan from the new hampshire
however with that promotion comes a
cute good afternoon mr chairman members
of the committee for the record paula
minihan senior vice president state
government relations with the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals in new
hampshire
the association is opposed to house bill
1495 this legislation would establish a
chapter of lara stated prohibiting
employee vaccine requirements for
government contractors except for
medical providers when there is a direct
threat present
however the bill itself goes well beyond
the stated analysis and is quite broad
there are several problems with this
bill first this bill is in direct
conflict with the federal requirement
for government contractors
to ensure that their employees are
vaccinated that requirement is currently
held up in court in a court challenge
and is likely not going to be settled
for months that is one valid reason to
not pass this legislation the confusion
and potential conflict that likely will
result between state and federal laws
and regulations is significant and
noteworthy while the bill before you
reference employees that contract with
the state of new hampshire the concern
is companies that have contracts with
the state may also and very likely do
have contracts with federal government
hence the conflict further the bill is
not consistent with the federal centers
for medicare and medicaid services cms
regulations relative to employee
vaccination requirements the citations
in the bill before you reference the
equal opportunity employment commission
eeoc while relevant to all employers
including healthcare facilities the
definition of direct threat is not
pertinent in the context of vaccine
requirements
the exemption
section of the bill and i think
someone's already pointed this out page
3 lines 1 through 17 is also very
problematic
specifically lines 2 and 3 are again
related to the eeoc not the federal cms
vaccine requirement
in fact the exemptions listed are in
direct violation of the cms requirement
so again if the bill were to pass there
would be a direct conflict between the
state and federal requirements for
hospitals and health care providers
that accept medicare and medicaid
funding this would put federal and state
matching fed medicaid funding at risk
for all hospitals and health care
providers this is a risk that should not
be ignored
hospitals new hampshire hospitals must
follow cms requirements as i think you
are well aware
and that all providers that accept
federal funds must require that their
employees receive receive the cova
vaccine with exemptions for medical and
religious considerations the bill before
you is in direct conflict with this
federal requirement and the u.s supreme
court has ruled a couple weeks ago on
this requirement and the court's
position and it stands it is not being
appealed this is the highest court of
the land
is that the federal government does in
fact have the authority to impose this
requirement
and requiring vaccinations of health
care workers from communicable diseases
is not new to hospitals in new hampshire
and i just listed all the various
vaccines
that hospital vaccination requirements
that hospitals have for a number of
communicable diseases
and we do believe it's the right it is
the absolute right thing to do for
health and safety of our patients our
staff and citizens of new hampshire
and as i have stated previously but to
be on record the vast majority of
hospital staff have been vaccinated
against coven 19 or have received
exemptions and we've heard from many
health care workers who support the
vaccine requirement to protect their
health and that of their patients the
bill before you
as stated in the fiscal note could also
have negative economic impact on the
state of new hampshire and result in
contract disputes that could result in
increased litigation this is very
concerning and should give the committee
pause when considering this bill and the
implications to the state for all these
reasons the hospital association is in
strong opposition to this bill and we
urge the committee to find it in
expedient to legislate thank you
any questions for ms minahan
representative
folsom
thank you chairman pearson thank you for
taking my question and this um may be
happening i i don't know so that's why
i'm i'm asking this question the last um
person representative soloway asked a
question about the threat um
determination
my curiosity question is when a hospital
mandates or cms mandates that all
of the employees be vaccinated does that
include the groundskeepers does that
include the bookkeepers who might work
in a different building
the electrician that's putting up lights
where there's no patients around are all
of those people
also even if they're private contractors
are all of those also under that mandate
so for i can speak to the hospitals um
and they all their employees um unless
there are they have
qualified for an exemption um they they
are required to meet the vaccination
requirement because if they are working
say in dietary
or in grounds keepers whatever they may
and in fact still come in contact with
patients and
employees and so it is a it is a uniform
across
as far as contractors i think there are
some
i believe that if you're coming into the
hospital that you do nee as a contractor
say that you're providing um
uh you know a mobile mri and you come
you know twice a week or whatever um
those contractors um also must follow um
that are coming into the hospital must
follow if you have a contract with the
hospital you must also follow the
vaccine requirement
follow-up yes um thank you
i think that where my brain is going is
not necessarily those contractors who
are going to have direct contact with
the patient
i'm thinking more the people that i mean
the groundskeepers
rarely have contact with the patient
the business offices things like that
and so when you look at um
the risk assessment
for those people
would
does it really have as high of a risk as
it does
you know working up the ladder dietary
nurses doctors
so um i think it's important to note
this direct threat is a eeoc this is not
part of the cms requirement this this
this language in here is not part of the
cms requirement
so
i can't really address how they're
defining it the cms requirement is is
is pretty straightforward
that if you are accepting me if you are
accepting federal funds you must fault
you must have your employees must be
vaccinated
with with the exceptions of medical and
religious
exemptions and they do have policies
which i actually owe you um i think um
and i apologize i've been a little busy
so i haven't had a chance to get that to
you but i think you had asked me last
week about the
what the policies um include for medical
and religious and i was going to show
you a form um i'm just i'm pulling that
together i will send that to the entire
committee
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um my question is
about your statement on the supreme
court um i'm i'm not sure if you
i'm curious if you've read the reports
on it or if you actually read the
opinion because the opinion wasn't a
ruling it was simply staying the
injunction so saying that there is merit
and they're continuing on before they
come to a final decision and i'm curious
if
knowing that it's an opinion and not a
ruling changes any of your opinions
there my understanding is the white
house asked that this be considered by
the supreme court they wanted a ruling
and they um so
my understanding is that that's the
ruling that was stated i i think you
there's also the government um
contractor that that one is being a um
is in
appeal right now or not appeal but it's
in the it's in the lower courts right
now but um i i am not under the
understanding and i had checked um
with the american hospital association
it's not our understanding that the cms
requirement is being further challenged
so i
that is not my understanding
follow-up
my follow-up would be
just trying to understand that this is
simply staying the injunctions and that
that is not a final ruling but i guess
um
your it's your understanding that
there's not going to be an actual ruling
on this and that the opinion is all
that's necessary from the supreme court
in order to make these ground keepers
i believe the supreme court um has the
final say and that was the under that
was why the the
administration asked them to rule on the
cms mandate that's
that's my understanding and follow-up
and your your understanding is that they
have an actual ruling and not just an
opinion
from the supreme i'm not a lawyer
my understanding is the cms manda the
cms requirement stands and and the
hospitals and health care providers are
implementing them throughout the country
the supreme court does get to make the
final ruling but not everything they say
is their final ruling
and i
would agree that it's still pending
from how i read it
any other questions yes representative
snow
thank you mr chairman
i i just to follow up on what
one of my colleagues asked earlier many
of these hospitals and
companies have contractors
where i live we have a contract with a
large groundskeeping company the same
people don't come all the time depends
on who's available does that mean that
every employee of that groundskeeping
company for example would have to
receive this
or
they would not be able to have a
contract same with
if you have to call it an electrician to
fix an electrical problem
again um depending on the policy of the
hospital but um and i have not seen the
the actual policies but my understanding
is if they are coming into the hospital
to provide services
that those that are coming in must be um
have proof that they are vaccinated
by or or they have an exemption they
have received an exception by in
do you mean into the building or well
they provide they're providing services
to that facility even if it's only
outside on the grounds
i
representative leon um thank you mr
chairman um this actually raised a
question for me do you know if that
includes contractors who are only
virtual and never set foot on the
property
it depends on the policy of the hospital
representative
right michael actually i pulled up the
full-time telework employees are
exempted
so that is they are not included
thank you
saying none thank you so much
and you know um
my dad always said you learn a lot more
about a person you think you are talking
about when you actually talk to that
person so since we've been talking about
what bia thinks i'd like to call uh
david is it janae
juve sorry
oh thank you so much it would even be
better if you had the mic on
i won't repeat all that
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is dave
giuve i don't often appear before this
committee uh but i am senior vice
president for public policy for the
business and industry association we
serve as new hampshire's statewide
chamber of commerce we have 400 plus
employer members
with over 80 000 employees in the state
i'm here today in opposition to the bill
i won't go on and on about it because
many of the points i wanted to make were
made by ms minahan but i do want to make
sure that the committee understands
that passing this legislation would put
some employers in the state in a
extremely awkward position of
either needing to comply with the
federal mandate or
comply with the state law they wouldn't
be able to do both they are in conflict
with each other
last year on legislation
that on a completely separate topic but
it did deal with
private sector companies that had
contracts with the state
i checked with commissioner arlinghaus
from our department of administrative
services because i was curious how many
companies were we talking about and
interestingly he didn't know for certain
but he said it was in the thousands so
there are a lot of companies that would
be impacted by this
like ms minihan i am not an attorney but
i do want to give some thoughts on the
subject of of the federal mandate and
what the supreme court did there were
three
separate
federal mandates the one we heard the
most about initially was for private
sector companies that had a hundred
employees or more
the court struck down the emergency
implementation of that mandate
so i would say that has gone away
temporarily osha is still working on the
normal schedule for that mandate so i
think it is possible it would come back
someday but not in the immediate future
the second mandate applied to private
sector companies that had con federal
contracts
and the court
allowed that mandate to be stayed by a
lower court that doesn't mean it goes
away it doesn't mean it can be
implemented it means it's in a holding
pattern until that lower court renders a
decision and then that could be appealed
to the supreme court
the third mandate is the one that you
folks had some conversation about
relating to those
employers that receive medicaid or
medicare funding and i don't know to me
you know i'm sure there is probably a
legal difference between a dis rendering
a decision and
rendering an opinion
but the fact is having rendered either
the opinion or the decision that mandate
is in place and is being
um
uh
it is requiring employers
in those areas to comply with it
the
other area i do want to touch on um
relates more to
philosophy than the practical impacts of
this legislation and the philosophy from
the bia is
that we don't think it's appropriate we
think it is overreached by the state to
try and dictate to private sector
employers what they should or should not
be doing in terms of providing a safe
and healthy work environment for their
employees so mr chair i appreciate the
opportunity to testify
i'd be happy to try and answer any
questions
all right i
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question
it's the second time maybe even the
third time i've heard
an employer having a safe environment
i also heard the term
immune
on page three shot down because
people have who've had covid
have
had a reoccurrence of covid so are they
really immune which goes back to natural
immunity
um the the the vaccines from everything
that i've heard in the last month and a
half
do not guarantee a safe work environment
is my fact natural immunity may be
safer than uh than the vaccine
so are we really preventing
employers from
a safe
safe work environment by by
implementing this bill or any bill
similar to it
well i mentioned i'm not a lawyer i'm
not a doctor either so i'm not really
prepared to
um
debate the effectiveness of the
vaccination i would say what you are
doing is preventing employers from
thank you
representative folsom
thank you chairman pearson and thank you
for taking my question this is a
business one but maybe also a legal one
you're not a lawyer you're not a doctor
um
if a contractor
has a license with the
facility all of a sudden this mandate
they then are required to have all their
employees that are going to be working
which may be all of their employees
working in this facility to have them
if they choose not to have them
vaccinated is there any legal recourse
they have because they feel that
their contract with that facility has
had undue pressure put on it
to
for to comply with something that was
not in place when their contract was
made
um i i don't really feel well qual i
think it's an excellent question i don't
feel well qualified to answer it because
i'm not an expert on contract law
i can tell you that while the
federal mandate for government
contractors was in place for the short
period of time that it was in place
it not only implied it not only applied
to the company that had the federal
contract it also applied to
uh smaller companies that may be
providing them with
the widgets that go into the making of
the product for the government contract
if those widgets were used
in in the product that that the
government contract was about
so
um
that concept was certainly introduced i
know that doesn't really answer your
question about
whether it's legal or whether there
would be the basis for a lawsuit i'm
just not really qualified to answer that
follow-up
yes do you think thank you do you think
that the uh
company that is making the widgets are
are um a threat to the health of the
people in the facility
i
i don't really have the ability to
answer that either because i don't know
if they have
employees that are are
uh going into the workplace of of the of
the larger company with the contract i
you know in some ways i have to be
honest it doesn't really matter very
much what i think it matters what the
law is and i guess that's part of my
bottom line
problem with this legislation is you're
putting employers
at risk of not being able to follow
federal law and state law at the same
time
any other questions
representative acton thank you mr chair
and uh thank you for taking my question
we've seen in in this situation of covet
coordinate i won't use the word
collusion it's coordination between the
government
and big business
to
stifle free speech
and um so the people i represent who are
the people not big business
not government are extremely
concerned that
the
the grouping of
this new grouping is is shutting us down
we can't even discuss this without being
de-platformed by facebook
uh various um
big tech um businesses so
can you at least admit that there's some
basis for pushback because of this kind
of
this kind of behavior that's going on
between business and government
well i'd have to respectfully
but strenuously disagree with your
characterization that this is some type
of collusion between government and big
business i will acknowledge
that
it's an emotional issue on both sides
and
i understand that those who
either don't want to receive a
vaccination or don't believe that they
work have strongly held feelings
but i'd also like to remind the
committee that there are a lot of other
people who work in these very same
places of business that also have strong
feelings about wanting to work in a
place that's as
is
healthy and safety as reasonably
possible so
i would
request that you think about everybody
that's in a place at work and not just
focus on
one
population that may or may not want to
have vaccinations
representative leon thank you mr
chairman
would you believe that some of the
people that have a problem with these
policies are actually that fully
vaccinated fully boosted themselves and
they're thankful for the choice to be
vaccinated but they oppose these
mandates because they believe it's
coercive
so the opposition is not just those who
don't want to be vaccinated
yes i would believe that but i would
also say that they aren't the ones who
would be impacted by a an employer
mandate for vaccination
follow-up
do you believe that if we can mandate
these types of things for the health and
safety of people in a business that
future mandates might impact things
other than vaccination
i
think that would be speculative and i
have been around long enough to know
that whenever a situation like that or a
proposal like that comes up there will
be full debate about it
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
do you have
any
statistics
on
companies that
weren't mandated before but now are
let's say you've got a landscaping
company
and you've got 20 employees and these
guys are just lawn mowers and they mulch
and they mulch and mule
and so now all of a sudden
you've got this crew and it's tough
getting these crews i mean i know some
businesses have just gone out because
they don't have enough guys to mulch and
mull
so let's say you've got and these crews
tend to not want to
go get a vaccine
i mean truthfully
so now all of a sudden the owner of this
business
has to say to his 20 guys okay you guys
you all have to go get a vaccine in
order for me to have this contract
working for this particular
company hospital whatever
would i would say it would have to be a
medical facility of some sort right
because that's the mandate
now
these guys
quit now the company is in real jeopardy
do you have do have you had that
situation occur do you have any
anecdotal uh evidence do you do you have
any any type of figures um not
specifically relating to the landscapers
i i can tell you
at the for the short period of time
where it appeared that there would be a
federal mandate on private sector
employers of 100 employees or more
we had a lot of our members
i don't know the percentage but it was
significant
they were extremely concerned about
implementing that policy because they
thought they would lose employees and
and this is a pretty tough work
environment anyway in terms of finding
employees so
i i don't have a study i can tell you
though that that was
a significant concern for many of our
members at the point where that hundred
employee mandate
looked like it was going to be
implemented
thank you representative knurk
this is actually a point of order i i
don't really think we should be trying
to discuss the issues about whether the
cms mandate is correct or not
it's there our job is looking at this
bill which is in conflict with the cms
mandate and how to resolve that but
we're spending a lot of time talking
about how that should be changed and we
have not got the power to do that so i
would suggest that we would
defer and move on and actually focus on
the bill in front of us
that was my thought let's try that
any questions on the bill in front of us
and the chair calls up aaron and tom
fallon they these ass for two minutes so
the group of two gets four
how's that
we will owe you one for your future
visit
and your friend
that's rafferty hi
and uh
yeah he's tired of all of this so but to
get to it uh
again we're talking about individual
freedoms with this uh
proposed bill we're not talking about
yeah yeah it's it's business rights but
it's an individual's freedom freedom to
work
and to work without coercion
it's great to say
medical and religious exemptions
if they're granted
people can i know of people that have
filed
religious and medical medical exemptions
and had them denied
and have lost their jobs
and
taking care of the individual residents
of new hampshire and the individual
taxpayers is something we have to focus
on well i agree that we have to comply
with federal uh mandates
do we applau do
it what is law and what is opinion when
we look at as as you re uh
brought up earlier with regards to the
supreme court
and where do we roll over and as as new
hampshire live free and die and say okay
they said so so we're going to do it
where do we question and to and have new
hampshire rights
so speaking for people that i've seen
lose their jobs
that may not have the courage to come
tony fallon
so there's a lot of people have said
that i'm not a doctor i'm not a
business owner i am a business owner
um
but also the companies and governments
aren't doctors you know again you know
from the earlier story
we spent a lot of time getting
individualized health care for my wife
and there's lots of options for staying
safe
the the problem with the current scene
that this is trying to address this bill
that which we do support tries to
address
is that is aaron kind of alluded to
companies have a lot of power
you know if you're if you're a
regular joe going out to get a job and
they say you must do this to stay your
job
that that's a substantial weight that's
a substantial burden to try to
you know walk away from
and yes i i know that medicaid
does require this and yes there's all
kinds of conflicts
but as a sole practitioner
architect
i had to sign
a religious exemption
can you guess why
it's because i'm on the board of a
non-profit that seeks to help with
addiction recovery and mental health uh
white horse recovery
medicaid made white horse recovery
because we take medicaid funds
i as a board member had to sign every
religious exemption i was i was blown
away so
yes of course there's plenty of
conflicts but
this is a big big deal when an employer
or a government body goes to play a
doctor which they are not there's lots
of other ways to say stay safe
we really don't think this vaccine is
safe at all there's plenty of
dangers with us
thank you
thank you very much for all your service
too
and next time you come back you get 46
extra seconds
excellent
and you know we've had dogs in this
committee room before and the chair is
very sympathetic to dogs coming in here
yeah
the chair recognizes
you know you've been here long enough i
got to get this right is it rusan or
russon
and your last name's not bedford and you
don't come from chester okay russ anne
chester from bedford and i'm gonna be
extremely brief i'm just actually wanted
to come up here because there were a
couple of people that wanted to speak
but could not stay so i'm passing around
what the the article that or the piece
of paper that they had they only had one
copy with them um so i passed that
around for all you folks so that you'll
have it they also gave me another
document
i don't know for sure if that was
something that they wanted to share with
okay if it is i will i will i will send
that to you this evening and and talk to
you about it um the bottom line is for
me is is that if private businesses want
to mandate things the reality is is that
in our gover in our society we allow
private businesses to do that however
what i strongly believe is that if
you're taking any kind of public funds
state or from my taxes if i don't want
it as a person of new hampshire i
shouldn't be supporting it
that's it
let me ask you a question absolutely
does it seem like
the federal government takes more and
more of our taxes and then sends them
back to our state so we can do stuff
with our money
only because it comes back from the feds
it has all these strengths attached
and that is extremely concerning i agree
with you 100
and i appreciate the question
thank you
mr representative soloway
mr chairman if i can just
point out to you
that we have some of the lowest
tax rate tax rates in the world
and
taxes were substantially higher under
the eisenhower administration let's go
back to that i'm that old and
in addition it was under the reagan
administration that we ended block
grants
to states and cities we don't get nearly
the money back from the feds that we did
before reagan canceled block grants
those tax and spend republicans do it
every time don't they
mr chairman when you get to be as old as
me you'll remember these things
when i get to be as old as you i will
have forgotten most things
as as a as a
as a former tax accountant
we get in the state of new hampshire at
least when i was doing tax accounting we
get less than 30 percent back because of
the taxes we pay to the federal
government new hampshire gets less than
30 percent back
i don't know if that's still the case it
was it was the case okay we're going off
we're going off the bill but but yep
from do it and i don't think it means do
it but it says do it on the bottom
remind us what do it is
department of information technology
wow correct
bonjour yeah
for the record my name is dennis goulet
i'm the commissioner for the department
of information technology
or doit
which is really responsible for the i.t
for the executive branch
but i think today a lot of what i'm
going to speak about would be applicable
for the other branches of government
as well from a technology perspective
i'm here
testifying in opposition because the
the language of the bill
in particular the the prescription
against contracting
companies with a certain
set of policies would put a significant
operational and financial burden on the
technology function for the state
and for those other
entities that are named that are
in scope for the bill as well but that
you know that's not my scope but i
recognize that that would be the case
we just when we saw the bill we did a
quick look at a handful of the larger
companies that are servicing us today
all of them
would not be eligible to do business
with new hampshire
based on their current policies
so
implementation should we decide to
implement this bill
then we would have to replace all of
those
contracts which i'm not you know each
one of them's written in their own way
over time so
haven't had any chance to go through
them and
find out whether we'd have to buy our
way out of them or not or whether we'd
put ourselves in breach by doing things
which could be the case
but what i would say is you know we
spent
many millions of dollars implementing
those systems in the first place
um one of them's the largest system one
of the largest systems in the state our
integrated eligibility system which i'm
sure you're well well aware of deloitte
is you know what would fall into that
category
um sure we could replace them
at a
significant cost and
in some of the cases when i look at it
you know things like running our email
and collaboration system which the
gen court runs the same system from
microsoft
i'm not sure there is a company that
would supply that service that doesn't
have
internal corporate policies that would
transgress the language of this bill so
we might not even have an option to to
move forward operationally so surprised
um you know there's there's the fiscal
notes
is inadequate um and if you told me
dennis go get me a fiscal note as
quickly as possible quick quick wouldn't
be very quick on this because it's very
far-reaching and and would require
detailed analysis of contracts and
functions and and actually company
policies which by the way are changing
all the time so we're seeing you know
we're seeing you know in some in some
cases where you know different companies
are changing their policies so
we might look at a policy with somebody
we're contracting with today and their
their policies may change over time is
as again we learn more about
you know what's the appropriate way to
to operate as a company and in their own
best interests so
i think that concludes my testimony uh
happy to answer any questions that folks
have
the chair calls nathan white and joseph
christie from dhhs
with 25 handouts
thank you mr chair uh my name is
my name is nathan white i am the
director of the bureau of contracts and
procurement at the department of health
and human services
and i'm joe kirsty the chief financial
officer for new hampshire hospital in
glencliffe home
i am going to speak to this bill from
the operations perspective the
department of health and human services
we have a centralized bureau of
contracting currently as of this morning
we had about 863 active contracts
the department contracts both with
healthcare facilities but also
consultants law firms
marketing companies i.t companies and a
variety of others it really runs the
gambit our department has as everyone
here wells know well knows we have many
divisions and many different operations
at this point in time it'd be difficult
to predict what the potential
impact on operations would be
specifically relative to the provision
prohibiting contractors
from establishing vaccine mandates
if we were to
move if if this were to move forward and
it were to become law
um we
we would potentially have to terminate a
number of our contracts like again i
can't determine uh how many that would
be um we would likely have we could have
the potential for a lapse in particular
types of services we would likely need
to go back out to bid oftentimes that
can result in increased costs
particularly given the current inflation
that we are experiencing
so with with that being said again at
this point in time the the immediate
impact uh would both be operational as
well as potentially financial in the
long run and uh echoing the the
sentiments of the attorney general's
office um as noted in the
in the fiscal note there could be some
potential litigation issues arising from
and just to add for new hampshire
hospital
so much my testimony
would be similar to other testimony i've
provided in recent weeks to this
committee
but i did just want to mention a few key
pieces relative to this specific bill so
there is a
exemption established in section 9 g
colon 3 for licensed medical facilities
but that exemption does limit the
application of a vaccine mandate to
instances where a direct threat exists
we're a little bit unsure as to
who or how that definition would be
applied it likely wouldn't be applied
consistently across facilities
but that limitation to specific
instances where a direct threat exists
likely would prevent us from
having a vaccine requirements as a
condition of employment for things like
measles and mumps and rubella etc etc
so we have similar infection prevention
concerns on this bill as we have in
priors a prior testimony that i provided
again because of that
application for the medical exemption to
only instances where a direct threat is
present
we do believe that would be conflicting
with the cms coven 19 vaccine mandate
as well as the exemptions that
representative canark previously
mentioned that are that would be new and
they are not spelled out in the cms-cova
19 vaccine mandate
so again those would likely
put us at risk for potential loss of
accreditation and the potential loss of
our
medicare and medicaid funding as well as
our dish funding
and then i would say the one last
risk relative to this bill for new
hampshire hospital and glencliff home
the
section 9 g5 establishes a liberal
application of house bill 1495 and
articulates that any application of the
bill which is held invalid is limited
only to the section in which
which is invalid
and so the department's unsure if the
medical facility exemption would extend
to contractors of new hampshire hospital
such as dartmouth-hitchcock
and so that would be a concern for us
dartmouth does provide all of our
psychiatric and medical services at both
facilities
and
without their services
and i would also say if that was to be
reprocured in some capacity any vendor
qualified to provide those services is
likely implementing the vaccine mandate
or the kova 19 vaccine mandate
so that would that would
almost cease operations for new
hampshire hospital and glencliff and i'm
happy to take any questions
this ends the hearing on house bill
1495.
we do have some other work that we're
going to be attending to
and if anybody here
thinks that this bill
could have a better chance if amended
then i would suggest
you folks get a hold of representative
lanzara the chief sponsor
or representative harvey bolia who spoke
before us
and connect with them
and see what you may come up with
now
that ends
the schedule for today and we're going
to exec a few bills
and before we do um
i just want to let you know something
that they do in congress and while
that's not usually a model for me
uh
there is one thing that they do
and that is if a representative has to
be away for illness
that representative is paired
with a representative from the party
opposite
so they wash
and that's fair
and
one of the republicans has left for the
day and one of the democrats has left
for today so if bills break
in a partisan way which i think these
are going to
it won't come out 11 ten it'll come out
ten nine
and i don't have to do that but i want
to
the fact that
the
vote differential
is balanced off
with that in mind uh please take out
permitting miners
over the age of 16 to obtain a
vaccination without parental consent and
the chair recognizes representative king
thank you mr chairman i'd like to make a
motion that this bill
be itl
representative king moves itl
representative kelsey i second that
second that
now we can discuss it doesn't have to be
i'll start things off with um i don't
have i'm still getting organized here
my
my interpretation of this this bill is
um
that
it takes away the parental rights
of um
of basically what is
considered a minor
at 16 years old
and there are many states that have a
precedent where
18 is that age so
i'll start things there
and picking up on that i have a handout
um
one of these official government things
and the
first column says age at which a person
may generally consent to health care
progressive states like new york
illinois and california the age on this
printout is 18.
alabama which i believe is not a
progressive state
it's 14.
and
south carolina ditto
and any thoughts i may have would be
impolite about that
so i guess what i'm saying to
build on what representative king you
just said
is that
seems pretty much
generally speaking now we know about an
emancipated child or somebody who's
pulled out of a home because it's a
horror show but generally speaking the
age is 18 no matter what color your
representative king i'll add one more
thing now that i have my notes in front
of me the the second part of
of uh not just the age but
uh it's indirectly related to the age
is can a 16 year old really understand
adverse effects and what what the
repercussions are and um
it's my feeling that
that is
i don't think they're old enough to
understand that and to be quite honest
with you
there are times in my
my lifetime i've had to make decisions
for my kids and i didn't fully
understand it so i know a 16 year old
would have a real hard time with that
anyone else wish to participate in the
discussion
um
i felt very grown up at 16 i mean some
of us are and some of us aren't
and
i know that
some of my
children who i also felt were mature for
certain ages made
birth control decisions and whatever
between 16 and 18. and so this bill to
the best of my understanding is
focused on allowing a child to get a
vaccine
and um i know we like the stories i have
a neighbor across the street
her dog was barking too much and i went
over to chat you know we're over the
fence neighbors
so i said oh you've vaccinated she goes
no i don't believe in that i'm like oh
okay you know whatever her 18 year old
daughter
wanted to get vaccinated because
the girl's
father this woman's ex-husband had had
several heart attacks and they didn't
she and her brother didn't want to bring
covet to their dad
and my neighbor didn't allow it and gosh
everybody over thanksgiving had coveted
so i no one died
but i'm just saying here was a
responsible teenager she was
18 soon to be 18 because if she was 18
she could have done it and her mother
prevented her from getting vaccinated so
and i i just thought that was a shame i
hope
that the children
and their dad do not have long lasting
effects from having
had covered but it didn't have to be and
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman if i read this
bill correctly
it says
permitting minors over the age of 16
which i believe means 17. look at line
three
at nine line three
of the bill
a minor 16 years of israel then it is
well
that's a
difference
then
of at least one year and if our current
law is 18
and the difference from 16 to 18 is two
from 17 to 18 is one right
um i think perhaps either the title of
the bill needs to be changed or there
needs to be the minute we need a little
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair
um
i'll be honest i'm i'm conflicted uh
being the father of three very lovely
daughters
not prejudiced of course
we've done background checks and they
say the same about you sir
i pay i paid them well
um
i can i certainly appreciate that i
would certainly like to know if they
were going to get a vaccination however
i also from personal experience when i
was growing up and
also from stories that my daughters
related and kids that they went to
school with when they were growing up
some of the kids in this age group
didn't have
the parents
and i think to me this is a might be
addressing
those in that age group
that would we would consider
that don't have the advantage
of parents
to help them
and to me that's
not not the kids that have parents and
have guidance
they're going to have that counseling
anyway but the ones
to me the ones that really need it
don't have the counseling i won't go
into detail but i could give you a
number of examples some very tragic
unfortunately
and i think of them
and my heart goes out
so i'm a little bit conflicted here and
i must confess i'm leaning to to
throw my hat for these kids
who are trying to grow up despite the
lack
of any support
thank you
as i read line six it is not just the
parent
it could be the legal guardian as well
and
i'm not quite sure how many 16 year olds
are fully emancipated out from under any
parental or guardianship
follow-up well that's that's in the
letter of the law but from a functional
perspective
and again some of the things i'm
recalling
uh which made the public eye uh when
they occurred back in the day
um
didn't the parents were there
in the letter of the law but were
totally absent in the functional
concept
i'm really kind of torn
um
when i listen to the testimony
and represent the king you brought this
up before and it's a very valid point
when you have a fully functional family
this law is not needed
however i do know
having a spouse has worked in the school
system for many years as a school nurse
to represent wood's point of view there
are many parents that are absentee
parents
that quite frankly
abandon the children
but they still have the legal
responsibility in the child's control by
that parent
so i'm torn because if you're functional
you don't need a law
however if you're not functional and the
child is really out there on their own i
mean literally on their own i can tell
you all kinds of horror stories that
turn my
hairs in the back of my neck from the
story she brought home what do we do
with those child those children how do
we help them
help themselves because they're not
getting the parental support they need
that's where i'm torn
i took
my experience of 47 years as a member of
the clergy and added to it my wife's
experience of 30-some years as a family
practice physician
and would say that there
are certainly those two
polls
the you know i tell people i'm an aco
um oh which is not an adult child of an
alcoholic it's an adult child of ozzie
and harriet
and i am one
and i know a lot of people who are i
also know the horror stories believe me
very closely the horror story sometimes
when i had to go in to a house with
police
they put me in front
and then they came in behind me i know
those stories but there's a lot of
families that are in the middle
where they're sort of there
and they're not horrible parents but
they're not great parents either
and for those parents to find out their
child went off and did whatever it is
now
may cause the
tenuous family dynamic to get worse
especially if god forbid the kid gets a
vaccine and there's a bad outcome and
all of a sudden the kid's real sick and
along the way the parents who have legal
and financial responsibility discover oh
the kid went off and got vaccinated on
something
what was a minor stink show will now
escalate and i wouldn't want the kids to
have that opportunity when what they
need to do is try to strive yeah with a
lot of yelling and door slamming but
strive for a better family system even
if it isn't the great one that i grew up
with
so i think there is that big middle
group of family units representative
leon
thank you mr chairman and you bring up a
great point while
we may disagree about how frequent
vaccine injury happens we there are
people
they do happen the question is a
frequency and because there's no
liability the families are left paying
for the consequences of of those
injuries
and it's one thing if the family decides
to do this and and says yes this is what
we believe is the right choice for our
family
but if a child
a 16 or 17 year old makes that decision
does that
and then they end up with myocarditis
and they end up having an expensive
hospital stay that is either on the
parent's insurance or they might be one
of these marginal families that's
getting by without insurance
we might be looking at a situation where
not only is that fracture of trust
because
where the child has gone out and
received this vaccination but now it's
also possibly threatening the loss of
their home we might be getting into
really really murky waters in some of
those marginal families where one thing
like this could tip them far over the
edge
and i we're kind of trying to nibble
around the problem of some parents not
being good parents but we're going to
throw a lot of people into that same
same stockpot and there's a lot of
families that we can actually make
things get worse
and i think that if we can just move
past this a little bit more and stop
trying to force i think there's a lot of
people that'll back off and realize
actually i do want this
and the less
and this is just one more march forward
that's increasing the distrust that
people are having and we need to rebuild
that trust we need to make sure that
that children are discussing their
choices with their parents and we're not
going to throw them under the financial
bus if they end up with one of these
representative shapiro yes thank you mr
chairman
um
i'll try to keep this brief because i
think this is one of the issues that
we're not going to convince each other
of
not going to change each other's minds
and um
and i'm of mixed minds you know
practicing as a family therapist for
you know i always wanted to bring
families together to like deal with
good parents bad parents if there is
such a thing
those are people's parents and those are
going to be the people in people's lives
and so the more we can bring people
together to decide on things together to
discuss things the better
that being said
i think we would all acknowledge that
the age of 18 is a pretty random um
choice to say that you're an adult when
you're 18 years old and you're not an
adult the day before
it's uh that's some
that's not god-given that's um
you know that's that's a that's a
man-made um distinction a person-made
distinction excuse me um that is uh i
was not offended and and we do need
something we you know we need something
to go by
um that that being said
um going back to
chairman pearson's
how many states um where the age of
consent for medical treatment is um 18
i would say that we did have a piece of
um
you know we did have a summary on a
different bill about mental health
treatment and if you look at that you'll
see that many many states
allow for consent to mental health
treatment at 12 and 14 at 16.
it looks to me like the majority of
states you can access mental health
treatment um before you're 18
without parental consent and i guess
you know
if your family is functioning reasonably
well and some of that is the luck of the
draw it's not only if you're good
parents i know great parents whose kids
have had a lot of problems
but if you're if your family's
functioning well
you don't really need to deal with this
at all because you'll just like discuss
it together and i guess my my last point
would just be that you know
since everyone's talking about how great
their kids are i would just say that i
have two daughters who are now way
beyond 16
who i would have absolutely trusted to
make this decision when they were 16
without any um
without thinking twice um
so i'm gonna vote for this but i
understand that some that frequently um
when we're making decisions were
there's um dueling
positives and negatives and um
and i happen to value both
family cohesiveness and parental
not parental rights but parental
responsibility for each other
and um and the rights of children
um so
i think we're just each going to take
our best stab at this one and i'm going
to vote for it
in addition to having three primary care
providers
the center i supervise has two
counselors
and i know my wife sometimes
when talking to a
between 16 and 18 year old
where
the child may not
opt on his or her own without parental
consent
discussions about
what the family situation was
and at that point
my wife and i believe the other two will
say we have two family systems
counselors here
and it sounds like your family's
not ideal but it's not horrid you don't
have to be pulled out by dcyf but it
sounds like you need to have a good sit
down as a family and have family systems
counseling and we have used what the
initial question of the
primary care provider was
as a teaching moment to see if we could
not enter into that and
i'm very grateful we have both of those
places in the same building on the same
team
but yes i understand um and i hope that
i'm like you in that um well i have one
great daughter but um
that
representative king
yeah i definitely appreciate
everything that i've heard from
the families that
probably don't have the support system
that they need to make this decision the
problem with law is that it includes
everybody
and so there's going gonna be a lot of
families that would be ill affected by
this and since we're talking about our
kids
uh i would trust my daughter with this
at 16
but i have three boys there's no way i
would have said i would have recommended
this
and
to give you an example i had one
actually i had two boys that wanted
pierced ears at the age of like 14 or
something like that and i said you can
get your ears pierced when my mother got
her ears pierced which was the age of
56.
and they didn't see the humor in that um
they did get pierced ears and then six
months later they let them dry up
because it wasn't as neat as they
thought it was
and then i had one who wanted tattoos in
the worst way and we said not until
you're 18 and i thought that was going
to be old enough for them to realize
and
he started getting tattoos and kept
getting tattoos until he was about 24
and then he got sick of tattoos so
um
i
to simplify this i i definitely hear
the other side of this and i and i
i just
i think that in general when we create a
law like this
16 is going to be too young for the
majority of them
and um
and i think that we really need to
protect the the kids in the the healthy
families until 18.
um i hear too many stories of healthy
families that think that they're healthy
and then their kids go off and they
either get a
something for an std or um
or
and you know the parent and the parents
want to be part of that decision thank
you
representative merchant
as i listened to what you're saying
recently
one of the things i just
at 16 you're still in school
and the schools require immunizations
so therefore in a lot of ways what i'm
thinking is the fact that there's a
backdrop to this
unless a child decides to drop out of
school which they have to do with
parents permission
in essence this bill becomes moot
because therefore the child is going to
get immunized unless they have a medical
exemption something like that even the
parent really can't exempt the child
from a vaccination when they're in
school is that
there is a bill to the effect that it
will
some at one point and those of you who
are better historians than i am
it was 21.
that's adulthood it's 21. we bumped it
and the statement was recently made
it is arbitrary it's not god-given it's
humanly devised
and 18 if that's the limit then the day
before well you can say that for 16. you
can say that for any age if 16 is now
the new normal
what about a day before that what about
next session when somebody bumps it down
to 14 what about when the children no
longer have to do what the parents say
and somebody will and if it isn't the
parents it might be
the government
thank you mr chairman speaking
tongue-in-cheek the nice news is that if
a kid gets to be 18 and goes into the
army they don't have to worry about
making a decision about immunization
despite your mask i see your tongue in
cheek representative kanark
thank you very much one of the things
that's important to remember is that
this has to do with obtaining
any vaccination
against the communicable disease we're
doing a lot of discussion of covid
but to remember that covet vaccine
may become something that's not as
controversial or even necessarily done
as much or may become just a routine
issue later on
one of the places where this really does
have an issue and it relates to the fact
that we do allow children to seek std
treatment earlier i do not think that
includes the hpv vaccination and we do
have a lot of difficulties as the human
papillomavirus
where parents say well no my kid doesn't
need to be vaccinated because they're
not sexually active
but the kid knows that they are sexually
active and they may want to get
protected against hpv
this would allow them to go get
protected again which i think this might
be the thing to be most likely to really
occur because for most other things most
parents aren't having a cow about
getting the mmr that's that's not a big
deal i think the major place we're going
to see this would be on hp hpv
vaccination where the child could say i
am active i want to be protected
i don't want cervical cancer and i want
to go get vaccinated for that and do
that without telling their parents
because their parents may not be fond of
the message
so it's for that reason that i do
support this bill
because i think that's the major place
where we might see some of this
uh active changes and require that sort
of the need
even in a good functional family that
may still be a taboo topic that would
lead a kid to want to be vaccinated
without their parents knowledge thank
you representative leon did i mean
excuse me representative delemus did you
have your hand up
and put it up in front of the mic thank
you
you have inherited representative snow's
custom
i have
you have
it is good company
thank you well i i thought i was pushing
the button all the time but maybe not
silly me
um we've got your back yeah thank you
mentioning the military you have to be
18 in order to uh join the military
unless you have your parents permission
right right at 17
and which i just confirmed with
representative king
and i know actually my mom's husband not
my father but a man i loved very dearly
actually
lied about his age and joined for world
war ii
into the navy
you know you're not i don't think you
you're not as at risk and i know that
there are other vaccines other than the
covet 19 but really the the hot topic
right now is the covid19 vaccine and we
know that there are a lot of injuries
vaccine injuries that are occurring and
when i get this piece of paper in front
of me
and it and it uh reinforces other
evidence that i've read and been given
you you look at 1 million over a million
adverse reactions and 23 000 deaths
following covet vaccines which is more
than all previous vaccines combined i
think that that
to
representative leon's point
what what if
god forbid
a young person goes out decides they're
going to get a vaccine and they don't
and the and the parents are like what
happened and they're like well your
child decided to go have a shot for a
vaccine for for uh covet it i just i i
think that
because of the the level of risk that we
see with this particular injection
i'm definitely going to be
voting against this bill
representative leon
thank you mr chairman all of this
discussion makes me think of my my
friend's father hal
his family never told him that there was
sudden cardiac death in the family and
he never found that out because he
dropped dead in front of his wife and
children
some of the reasons why parents aren't
getting somebody getting their child
vaccinated
is medical and
is it our job it's not our job to make
sure that those families are sharing
what might be an outside risk whether
there's uh outsized wrist because they
might have a clotting disorder something
else that predisposes them to an adverse
reaction
and
do we put those families that haven't
shared that with their child who may
have anxiety or other things that might
just concern them more than they're
willing to do before they fully launched
as an 18 year old do we just throw out
those families as well so i i appreciate
wanting to make sure that there can be
access especially for the hpv vaccine
that might be something that
if this doesn't pass maybe we come
around and try and figure out if that's
something that makes sense in the future
because i i've i've definitely talked
about vaccines and when you can consent
to the behavior that's when i'll let you
make that choice
and i think that's valid
but right now we're talking about
students who are having their washington
dc trip cancelled because of uncertain
vaccination status i mean you're talking
about a 16 year old that's dealing with
a lot of peer pressure
do we want to let them give in to that
peer pressure or not and that's why i'm
going to be on the side of itl hopefully
we can consider that continue the the
discussion about this these other cases
but i think that that's too big a
decision to be made outside of the
parents
i know it's too late for talking about
one of the things that i'm looking for
here is that
when there's a lack of
parental guidance
where does the child turn to
there's nothing in here that says they
can go somewhere
the only way they can do is go to court
and become an emancipated minor which is
a huge step to resolve something which
could be done otherwise and there's
nothing in here that says the child has
a recourse when is that
lack of parenting and they need
desperately to get a parent but they
representative folsom thank you
i think that
whenever i hear about
people assuming that 16 year olds
are fully capable of making some really
mature
decisions
i often think back to
a conversation i had with a military
recruiter i'm not going to tell which
branch
and i said why do you take our best why
do you take the 18 through 25 year olds
and he said because they think they're
invincible
and they'll do anything that all the
rest of them are doing
and you want to talk about peer pressure
though if one guy in the squad says yeah
let's go the rest of them just go and do
it even if it's one of the stupidest
things they could possibly do
they do it
my boys
have a few tattoos
very prominent large tattoos
expressing certain opinions on things
and now it's going to cost them a whole
bunch of money if they want them taken
off which
now they're saving their money to do
so
i really
i really cannot go with 16 year olds
making a decision
of putting something in their body they
cannot take back out
a tattoo as much as i regret it at least
you can spend a lot of money and make
plastic surgeons happy
by getting them erased
you cannot erase
an injection
point of order it does not work on your
dna i'm sorry but that is simply
false and i'm going to have to make a
point of order it does not work on your
dna whatsoever
and it doesn't work on the irony it is
rna but it does not affect rna may i
actually make one other point of order
just just this same clarification the
various reports again do not imply
causality at all
they are mandated if there's any death
and in the 17
sorry 14 deaths between ages 12 and 17
in new hampshire
again remember two of them were from
suicide
that was not because they got the covet
vaccine and none of them have actually
upon full detail and an investigation
have been proven to be caused by the
vaccine although there are still a few
where their full information is pending
okay i think we're about ready to stop
kicking this one down the road but
representative leon
thank you and just a point of order as
well because of the crossover and the
initial study
the vares is not a perfect system at all
but it's pretty much the only long-term
follow-up we have so we have to take it
warts and all
and no it has warts are you ready for
the question
question before us
house bill 1126
the motion is itl
so if you don't like the bill you vote
yes if you like the bill you vote no
that's how sometimes things work and we
all get confused with that so
um
seconded by representative kelsey
will the clerk please call the role
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus yes
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk
no
representative soloway
representative cannon
yes
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no
representative woods no
representative merchant
yes
representative pearson
twelve to seven i'm i now i'm starting
to count if they're not unanimous so i
don't miss make mistakes you know
i think a lot of us wish we could could
have squared this circle because that's
who we are and what we do and we really
know we have two hands as in on the
other hand and i appreciate those as
saying maybe we need to come back
with something another time particularly
on the points that a
few of my colleagues made um with that i
closed the executive session on 11 26
and close at today's business we'll see
thank you representative king
a majority committee report and
democrats
who voted on the negative side
who would you decide amongst yourselves
to write the
you